Und da sind wir wieder am Ende des Monats am letzten Donnerstag im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, wo jeden Monat einmal der Chaos Computer Club oder Leute, die aus dem Umfeld kommen, hierher kommen und über ein Thema ihrer Wahl reden, das meist damit zu tun hat, dass ein technisches Problem oder ein technisches Konzept, das für unser Leben wichtiger ist, als wir vielleicht glauben, der Öffentlichkeit mal bekannter gemacht wird. Da sind heute unter anderem zu Gast der Herr, jetzt haben wir gar nicht mehr den Namen gesprochen vorher, was man eigentlich mal machen muss. Mit Andreas spreche ich auf jeden Fall.
Andreas, ja das ist ganz einfach.
Und der andere heißt?
Thorsten oder THS.
Und irgendjemand hat sein Handy mit dem Studio. Wer ist denn das? Ja, so kann es gehen. Wir wollen heute über etwas sprechen, was Disclosure heißt. Was ist Disclosure? Nun ja, also möglicherweise habt ihr schon mal vor eurem Computer gesessen und habt keine andere Webseite aufgesucht oder habt ein Programm aufgerufen oder ein Spiel gespielt und plötzlich ist es abgestürzt. Es gab eine komische Fehlermeldung und ihr dachtet so, da hat doch noch jemand sein Handy in der Nähe.
Ich hab diverse. Ich schalte die gerade alle aus.
Jetzt ist aus. Dass man nach Jahren immer noch zur Ordnung ruft, einmal mit Profis. Sehr gut. Also ihr sitzt vor einem Rechner und zum Beispiel kommen da komische Geräusche raus oder irgendein anderer Fehler passiert und ihr denkt euch, was ist denn da los und lasst es dann einfach bleiben und kommt wieder, wenn es ganz gemacht wird. Für manche Leute beginnt da ist der interessante Teil, denn so eine Fehlermeldung in einem technischen System ist oft der Anfang für, könnte man das feindliche Übernahme nennen oder Sicherheitsproblem, Sicherheitsschwankung ist das Wort, das ihr gerne benutzt, oder?
Ja oder der Anfang vom Ende, wie auch immer, also das kann man sehen, wie man möchte.
Das heißt, so ein Fehler in einer Software ist es ja meistens, egal wo die gerade versteckt ist, kann dazu führen, dass man ein System angreifen kann und dann übernehmen. Und Disclosure bezeichnet den Vorgang, wie man das Ganze an die Öffentlichkeit bringt. Oder es geht schon darum, dieses Sicherheitsproblem, das es da gibt in einer Software, möglicherweise an die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen.
Genau. Man könnte es ganz plakativ so sagen, wie in einem legendären Deoxys-Chase-Thread damals im Usenett in den 90ern. Ich habe gehackt, was nun?
Ah, das ist das Problem. Also man sitzt sozusagen als Hacker vor einem technischen System, hat einen Fehler rausgefunden und denkt so, hm, was mache ich jetzt damit? Was macht man dann damit?
Ja, also Spaß haben. Oder auf Ruhm und Ehre hoffen, indem man das Ganze eben veröffentlicht, irgendwie, irgendwo und diese Veröffentlichung kann man natürlich auch auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise durchführen und darüber wollen wir heute reden.
Darüber wollen wir heute ein bisschen genauer reden. Das ist ja der erste Punkt, was muss eigentlich passieren, bevor ich denke, okay, jetzt ist es wirklich soweit, dass ich damit an die Öffentlichkeit gehen kann. Also in welcher Form, das besprechen wir gleich noch, aber was ist denn so das Stadium eines Angriffs oder der Entdeckung einer Sicherheitsschwankung, dass man durch Schritten haben muss, bevor man sagt, okay, jetzt ist es dafür bereit, jetzt ist der Rest der Welt auch dafür bereit?
Naja, also man sollte sich vielleicht schon darüber, also man sollte sich schon vergewissern, dass das, was man da gefunden hat, vielleicht wirklich einen Impact hat, also etwas zur Folge hat, was negative Konsequenzen hat für alle Leute, die diese Software oder diese Geräte oder was auch immer benutzen. Also wenn ich an die Öffentlichkeit gehe mit irgendeinem Bug, der sicherheitskritisch ist und da Impact hat, dann bin ich natürlich bemüht da für meine Thesen, die ich da aufstelle und all das, was ich da behaupte auch Beweise mit zu liefern. Das heißt, ich erforsche diesen Fehler schon so tief, dass ich auch weiß, ich kann ihn irgendwie triggern, also auch tatsächlich ausnutzen, sodass mir am Ende der Vendor, der Softwarehersteller und der Benutzer auch zuhört, weil ansonsten hören die alle weg und sagen auch...
Also ich brauch zu sagen, nicht nur ein theoretisches Konzept, sondern auch eine praktische Anwendung. Wenn man sich ein bisschen belesen hat, vielleicht irgendwie so ein heißes Newstick oder sowas nicht, dann liest man ab und zu von einem Proof of Concept, dass da eine größere Rolle zu spielen. Das heißt jetzt natürlich Beweis der Machbarkeit, aber was bedeutet das genau in diesem Fall von Sicherheitslücken in einem technischen System?
Naja, es sollte sozusagen für den geneigten technisch versierten Leser nachvollziehbar sein, dass da tatsächlich ein Problem existiert. Das ist mein Proof of Concept. Das heißt, es muss noch nicht die fertig ausgearbeitete Lösung sein, mit der man dann also auf Knopfdruck irgendwo einbrechen kann, aber man muss verdeutlichen, dass es möglich ist, das zu einem Punkt zu entwickeln, wo eingebrochen werden kann. Das ist auch so ein bisschen so eine kleine Kunst dabei, sozusagen das schon technisch zu demonstrieren, dass es ein Problem ist, dass man da illustriert. Auf der anderen Seite aber nicht gleich das Werkzeug mit zu liefern, um größeren Schaden anzurichten, um auch den Nutzern von der Software die Zeit zu geben, die Patches einzuspielen.
Okay, das ist sozusagen der wichtige Punkt, wo sich dann diese Disclosure, also die, das an die Öffentlichkeit bringen, unterscheidet. Und das steckt auch im Sendungstitel heute ein bisschen drin. Es geht um Responsible und Full Disclosure. Was ist der Unterschied?
Na, Responsible Disclosure hat so ein bisschen das Ziel, dass möglichst wenig Schaden in der Öffentlichkeit entsteht, durch die Veröffentlichung von einem sicherheitsrelevanten Bug. Das heißt, man gibt dem Softwarehersteller genügend Zeit, auf dieses Problem zu reagieren, indem er den technischen Sachverhalt verstehen kann. Also der Softwarehersteller, der Besitzer dieses Problems, muss jetzt verstehen, was genau verkehrt ist. Er muss dieses Problem akzeptieren und dann an einer Lösung arbeiten, wie dieses Problem systematisch im eigenen Code beseitigt werden kann. Und dann muss so ein Softwarehersteller, je nachdem, wie groß und komplex die Software ist, daher auch noch diverse Tests durchführen, die auch wieder eine Weile dauern, dass eben dieser Bug-Fix nicht irgendwelche anderen Probleme aufreißt. Und dann muss irgendwann ein Patch bereitgestellt werden, der dann an die User verteilt wird. Das nimmt alles Zeit in Anspruch. Und irgendwann muss dann der Softwarehersteller auch sagen, okay, jetzt haben wir lange genug gewartet. Zwei Wochen müsste genug sein, dass jetzt die User diesen Patch halt installiert haben. Und dann kann man halt mit dem Softwarehersteller einfach vereinbaren. An dem Datum veröffentlichen wir dann halt eine öffentliche Warnung, ein Advisory, was alle Leute darauf hinweist, dass es ein Problem gibt. Und dann haben die eben die Möglichkeit, da auch nochmal schnell irgendwelche Patches zu installieren.
Also Responsible heißt ja auch verantwortungsvoll und das ist sozusagen der nette Weg eigentlich. Man findet also in irgendeiner Software oder im technischen System eine Sicherheitslücke und sagt erstmal dem, der das System produziert, guck mal, du hast da ein Problem. Der fixt dann das System und sozusagen, wenn ihr ein Softwareupdate wieder mal bei eurer Konsole, bei eurem System, was auch immer, seht, dann kann das möglicherweise damit zu tun haben. Aber dann will man doch, als derjenige, der diese Sicherheitslücke gefunden hat, das nochmal selbst veröffentlichen. Warum will man das überhaupt selber machen und überlässt das nicht einfach dem Hersteller?
Wegen des Fames.
Also man will berühmt werden. Gibt es dann sozusagen, ist das so wie eine Medaille, die man sich anheften kann, ein Achievement, wie die Gamer sagen?
Genau, genau. Da gibt es dann Gummipunkte für, also Streetcred.
Nein, ernsthaft, kann mir das helfen, irgendwie einen Job zu finden später? Natürlich, natürlich.
Klar.
Irgendwelche Sprayer, die ein Loch in einem Zaun bei der Bahn finden und dann anfangen die Züge zu besprühen, das ist dann für die wahrscheinlich genau der gleiche Fame, den sie da erlangen können. Also vielleicht kann man das ja damit vergleichen.
Also tatsächlich hilft es auch beim Jobs finden. Wenn man irgendwie drei, vier, fünf Sachen gefunden hat, dann hat man relativ gute Chancen, irgendwo hin zu laufen und zu sagen, guten Tag, ihr habt da so eine Stelle als Senior Penetration Tester oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist halt eine Veröffentlichung und die kann einem dann auch keiner mehr nehmen. Das ist halt einfach, du bist der Erste, der den Bug gefunden hat. Am Ende ist scheißegal, wie du den Bug gefunden hast, ob durch Zufall oder durch gezielte Suche. Das ist ja auch nochmal die Frage. Aber im Grunde genommen hilft dir das natürlich auch, wenn du entsprechende Jobs suchst in dieser Branche.
Wenn man jetzt so einen Fehler gefunden hat, was sind denn eigentlich die Konsequenzen davon? Also die Horrorenvorstellung ist natürlich immer so, oh nein, jemand übernimmt meinen Rechner und ist da komplett drin und überwacht mich und kann alles machen, was ich auch mache. Ist das nötig für so eine Sicherheitslücke oder was sind die Auswirkungen, die man da festlegen kann oder gibt es da alles?
Na es muss schon irgendwas sein, was dem Angreifer in irgendeiner Art und Weise hilft. Also es muss nicht das komplette Ding sein von ich sehe dein Rechner von Weitem zu ich lese alle deine Mails. Aber es muss zumindest auch dem Weg ein Stückchen helfen. Also wenn, keine Ahnung, man einen Bug hat, der einem Administratorrechte verschafft, dazu muss man aber vorher Administrator sein, dann ist es irgendwie sinnlos. Wenn man einen Bug hat, der einem normalen User erlaubt, Administratorrechte auf dem Rechner zu bekommen, dann ist es interessant. Das heißt noch nicht, dass ich in dein Rechner einbrechen kann, weil ich kann ja noch nicht normaler User werden. Aber wenn ich erstmal ein normaler User bin, kann ich Admin werden und z.B. in den Cryptokies rankommen. Das wäre ein Bug, der also total legitim wäre, den zu reporten.
Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen auch bei der Anfälligkeit von Technosystemen sozusagen eine Beliebtheitsskal. Also ein Fehler kann ja trotzdem ganz irgendwie viertelig für ein Programm sein, aber wenn er nicht ausnutzbar ist, ist er nicht so interessant?
Na, es sind eher verschiedene Stadien, die du da durchgehst. Nehmen wir mal einfach dieses sehr populäre Beispiel eines Jailbreaks für so ein iOS-Device.
Also die Möglichkeit, dass man sozusagen andere Software drauf installiert als die von Apple.
Da braucht man ja nicht einfach nur einen Exploit, eine Sicherheitslücke, die man ausnutzen muss, um dieses Telefon zu jailbreaken. Da braucht es halt mehrere Sicherheitslücken, die ausgenutzt werden müssen. Das ist eben einmal entweder etwas remote, dass man überhaupt erst mal eine Code Execution hat auf dem Device, meinetwegen in irgendeinem Browser, dann hat man eben weniger hochprivilegierten Code, der da ausgeführt wird und dann braucht man noch eine weitere Sicherheitslücke, die eben so eine Privilege Escalation ausnutzen kann. Das, was Andreas gerade sagte, dass man eben Root-Rechte erlangen kann oder eben Super-User-Rechte und dann eventuell auch Code im Kernel ausführen kann.
Ich will das, weil es jetzt noch mal sehr viele Worte waren, also Fremdworte, noch mal zusammengefasst. Also es gibt einen kleinen Fehler und der ist meistens der Anfang dafür, dass man immer tiefer ins System vordringt.
Ja, das sind halt einfach mehrere Hürden, die man dann nehmen muss, wenn man wirklich mal was ernsthaft unterwandern will und vielleicht eben auch noch irgendein Root-Kit oder irgendwas Persistentes auf dem System installieren möchte, was auch nicht entdeckt wird.
Also Root-Kit sind dann die Sachen, wo man wirklich das System tatsächlich dann von außen bedienen kann.
Das ist halt so das klassische, was man halt so kennt, bei der typischen Schad-Software oder bei den Staatstrojanern oder was auch immer.
Da kommen wir später noch auf zurück übrigens. Also ein einzelner Fehler, eine einzige Sicherheitslücke muss noch nicht sozusagen alleine komplett ein ganzes System kaputt machen können, aber ist trotzdem interessant zu erforschen für diese Zwischenschritte, weil es da einer von sein kann. Aber natürlich wäre es möglicherweise dann auch eine Reaktion von einem Softwaresteller, zu sagen, mit dieser Sicherheitslücke alleine kann man ja noch gar nichts anfangen. Dazu kommen wir aber später. Wir wollen jetzt noch den anderen Teil vorstellen, es gibt Responsible Disclosure und das andere ist Full. Also Responsible ist, ich gehe hin und sage, hier Hersteller, fix das mal, wir geben dir, gibt es da eine vorgeschriebene Zeitdauer? Also gibt es da so einen Mittelweg, wo man sagt, okay, dann muss es aber fertig sein?
Na, es gibt verschiedene Ansätze und es gibt da keinen Zwang, sich an irgendwas zu halten. Also es gibt verschiedene Empfehlungen, also es gibt halt irgendwie das Cert, was halt sagt, wenn man den Hersteller von so einer Software auf so einen Fehler hinweist, dann setzt man ihm eine Frist von 45 Tagen, die er Zeit hat, das zu fixen, zu testen und einen Patch zu releasen und dann kann man das Problem veröffentlichen. Dann gibt es irgendwie Vorgaben, zum Beispiel von Google, die halt sagen, nehmt doch 60 Tage und dann gibt es eben auch andere Stellen. Ein Beispiel, was ich eben gerade erst gehört habe von niederländischen Forschern, die halt was gefunden haben, die haben halt darüber berichtet, dass die niederländischen Behörden zum Beispiel empfehlen, eben für Software-Bugs 60 Tage anzusetzen und für Hardware-seitige Bugs sechs Monate, weil das einfach aufwendiger zu fixen wäre. Wobei man da natürlich sagen muss, wenn das wirklich echte Hardware-Bugs sind, sind die in der Regel nicht so zu patchen. Also das Einzige, was man da machen kann, ist halt irgendwie Geräte zurückzurufen, wenn das irgendwie wirklich echt ein Hardware-Problem ist, wenn ein Schaltkreis falsch ist, den man ausnutzen kann irgendwie. Andernfalls, wenn es eben um so embedded-Devices geht, dann ist das ja doch am Ende auch Software, also die Firmware, die man dann möglicherweise patchen kann. Also kommen wir wieder auf die 60 Tage zurück.
Jemanden aber vielleicht sagen, nicht so einfach patchen kann, weil es irgendein Bauteil im Auto ist oder so was.
Ja, das ist dann halt einfach teuer und aufwendig.
Okay, also wie gesagt, zur Motivation dessen, was Hersteller solcher Systeme mit solchen Meldungen machen, kommen wir gleich noch. Jetzt, was ist Full Disclosure?
Ja, das ist so, man postet eine Mail auf der Meldungsliste, sagt irgendwie, lol, haha, guck mal, ist alles kaputt.
Drückt man es ein bisschen gewählter aus?
Da kannst du freestylen. Also ich meine, viele Leute, die Full Disclosure machen, die haben halt auch entsprechend negative Erfahrungen mit Responsible Disclosure gemacht und sagen halt einfach so, ach, leckt mich doch alle, jetzt gibt es was auf die Ohren.
Ja gut, also jetzt trotzdem nochmal in gewählten Worten bitte erklärt. Also das heißt, ich habe eine Sicherheitslücke, bin ich auch in dem Stadium, dass ich ein Proof of Concept erarbeitet habe und sowas?
Genau, genau, jetzt brauchst du auf jeden Fall, sonst machst du dich lächerlich, wenn du überhaupt das hast, als Sicherheitslücke, wenn du es nicht zeigen kannst und Full Disclosure heißt einfach, ich schreibe das auf eine der einschlägigen Mailinglisten, eine heißt zum Beispiel Full Disclosure überraschenderweise und ja, da erklärt man halt, was das Problem ist und wie man es ausnutzt und in der Regel gehört da noch so ein bisschen Freestyle dazu, dass man irgendwie sich über diesen Bug lustig macht, aber das ist nicht notwendigerweise Voraussetzung.
Was ist da dann das Vorgehen des Herstellers?
Ja, da wird dann die PR-Abteilung angerufen und dann erklärt das alles gar nicht so schlimm ist und im Zweifelsfall. Also Full Disclosure machen Leute auch nicht immer unbedingt unter ihrem echten Namen.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt zu empfehlen, je nachdem, was man da für ein Bug findet.
Aber das hört sich jetzt für mich schon so an, als ob Full Disclosure eigentlich die zweite Wahl ist.
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an. Also es gibt durchaus Hersteller, gerade aus dem Open Source Bereich, wo ich mittlerweile auch sagen würde, Responsible Disclosure hat einfach gar keinen Sinn, weil man mit denen nicht zusammenarbeiten kann. Den Schreibbaum hat er einen Bug und dann wird er zwei Jahre nicht gefixt.
Aber das ist ja trotzdem der zweite Versuch, weil du triffst diese Entscheidung, weil du...
Nicht für diesen Bug, aber mit diesem Hersteller. Dann weiß ich am Ende, geht ja auch ein bisschen um Verantwortung, wenn ich jetzt mit denen versuche, einen Responsible Disclosure Prozess anzustarten, dass der Bug nie gefixt werden wird. Und dass es für die Nutzer eigentlich gesünder ist, wenn dieser Bug schnell gefixt wird, als wenn jemand anders ihn unabhängig entdeckt und damit dann Mist baut. Also auch wenn ein Bug tatsächlich schon in the wild exploited wird, also wenn jemand da draußen rumläuft und mit dem Bug Rechner aufmacht, dann hat es in der Regel auch keinen Sinn, irgendwelche zwei Monate langen Prozeduren abzuwarten, sondern sagt man gleich, guck mal hier, hier ist gerade einer bei mir eingebrochen, funktioniert so und so, wie der Schaden ist entstanden. Da läuft eh schon jemand rum und bricht in den Rechner einen, da haben wir nichts davon, wenn ich das niemandem erzähle. Wenn ich das jetzt gleich erzähle, dann haben wir wenigstens alle dieselbe Chance, es schnell zu fixen, schnell einen Wirkpunkt zu finden.
Oder eben Workaround einzusetzen, der das System halt vielleicht temporär.
Das hat man ja früher beim Internet Explorer häufiger gehört, ja bitte jetzt mal die nächsten vier Wochen nicht, ja was kann man benutzen, weil irgendwas ist schlimm.
Das wäre halt ein Workaround.
Okay, so, aber noch mal genauer aufgeschlüsselt, was ist jetzt das Positive an Responsible Disclosure? Also nicht sofort an die ganze Öffentlichkeit zu geben, sondern erst mit dem Herrschaufförer zu sprechen. Was sind die Vorteile davon für denjenigen, der es veröffentlicht, für den Hersteller und für die Öffentlichkeit?
Für den, der es veröffentlicht, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit geringer, dass er von der betreffenden Firma verklagt wird. Für die Öffentlichkeit ist der Vorteil, dass man möglicherweise es schafft, allen Nutzern eines Produktes, allen Nutzern einer Software einen Patch zur Verfügung zu stellen, bevor bekannt wird, dass es diese Sicherheitsprobleme gibt. Es ist ja immer so ein Wettlauf, die Leute auf der dunklen Seite sind relativ fix. Wenn ein neuer Java-Bug rauskommt, kommen am nächsten Tag die Export-Kits, die den ausnutzen. Das heißt, man hat so ein Zeitfenster von 24 Stunden, bis die bösen Jungs kommen, den Bug ausnutzen. Und wenn dann in dem Moment, wo der Bug bekannt wird, alle Nutzer schon den Patch haben im Idealfall, dann ist sozusagen aus utilitaristischer Sicht der Nutzen für die größte Zahl der Leute am größten.
Aus was für Sicht?
Utilitarismus.
Ja, das musst du jetzt bitte erklären.
Das ist die Maximierung des größtmöglichen Nutzens für die größtmögliche Zahl Leute. Das ist eine philosophische Tradition.
So, was ist das Positive am Full Disclosure?
Man muss sich nicht mit dem Hersteller abgeben und man muss nicht mit ihm diskutieren. Ich glaube, das ist so der Hauptvorteil, denn das kann auch ganz schön mühsam sein.
Also man sagt...
Wie Andreas schon sagte, es gibt halt Hersteller und ich denke, dass das halt gerade auch sehr verbreitet in der Open Source Community.
Das hat niemand PHP gesagt.
Ist das sozusagen ein System, das besonders bekannt dafür ist, Full Disclosure zu erleiden zu müssen?
Ich glaube, die haben Security Bugs von mir immer noch nicht gefixt nach zwei Jahren.
Okay, so der Nachteil ist bei Full Disclosure anscheinend, deswegen machen wohl manche Leute auch anonym, dass man dann verklagt werden kann von den Herstellern.
Das kann auch passieren, wenn man Responsible Disclosure macht, aber bei Full Disclosure ist das halt schon sehr offensichtlich, dass man da auch echt schadet. Also ich denke, das ist dann sehr stark abhängig davon, was man da eigentlich veröffentlicht. Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie eine schwerwiegende Schwachstelle in so einem Apache-Web-Server veröffentlicht, dann hat das schon mehr Impact, als wenn das irgendwie nur ein Cross-Site-Scripting in so einem PHP-Web-Forum ist.
Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, was du gesagt hast, aber es gibt schlimme und weniger schlimme Sachen.
Ja, also das kommt eben darauf an, was kann dadurch passieren? Es kann ja durchaus passieren, dass dadurch ganze Netzwerke übernommen werden können von irgendwelchen bürsartigen Leuten oder dass es eben ein Bug ist, der vielleicht so fies ist, den man gar nicht so schnell fixen kann. Also dass man vielleicht irgendeinen Bug in irgendeinem Design gefunden hat, irgendeinem Protokoll. Wenn man diesen Bug beheben müsste, müsste man vielleicht das ganze Protokoll anfassen. Und dann hätte so ein Hersteller einfach sehr lange Zeit brauchen, diesen Bug zu beheben und auch durchzutesten. Und in diesem Zeitfenster zwischen, der Hersteller hat davon mitbekommen, bis es gibt einen Patch, können dann vielleicht sogar Tage liegen. Und in diesen Tagen können Schadsoftwareautoren, vielleicht auch Würmer schreiben, die sich halt selbsttätig vermehren und diesen Bug ausnutzen. Und das kann dann schon ganz schön problematisch werden. Wenn natürlich die ganzen Snake Oil Hersteller hinterher sind und irgendwelche Signaturen veröffentlichen, kann man das Problem möglicherweise ein bisschen eindämmen, aber das ist halt schon eine besonders fiese Sache.
Und da läuft man in eher Gefahr sozusagen, dass man auch Ärger mit der Rechtsabteilung bekommt?
Ja, also vielleicht auch nicht nur mit der Rechtsabteilung.
Aha, dazu kommen wir noch genauer. Was ist denn der Negative oder der Nachteil, wenn man Responsible Disclosure hat? Ich meine, eigentlich ist es doch so, ich persönlich als Veröffentlicher weiß ja, was schlimm ist, kann mich selber dafür schützen und die anderen kriegen es ja erstmal nicht mit. Was kann da schon groß schiefgehen?
Ja, also wenn man einen kooperativen Hersteller hat, der tatsächlich Interesse daran hat, den Bug zu fixen, dann ist das eine gute Sache. Also Full Disclosure ist eher so die… Genau. Die Möglichkeit, Druck auszuüben, wenn die Jungs halt nicht mitspielen.
Man sitzt am längeren Hebel, man hat Wissen und man hat möglicherweise Kot und kann halt einfach sagen, ey Leute.
Ja, aber das sind ja nicht die negativen Seiten von Responsible Disclosure.
Ja, aber mir ist es sehr oft passiert, dass die entsprechenden Hersteller, die auch wenig Erfahrung haben, da kommen jetzt Leute und submitten uns Kot, obwohl wir die gar nicht dafür bezahlt haben, da überhaupt nachzusuchen, die kommen dann an und sagen, ja, unterschreib doch erstmal dieses wundervolle NDA, also diese Geheimhaltungsvereinbarung und dann können wir uns weiter unterhalten. Das ist schonmal so der erste Schritt, wo die dann auf die Dove versuchen, einen erstmal im Mund tot zu machen.
Okay, also wir wollen ja gleich noch genauer darüber sprechen, wie sich diese Hersteller gegenüber solchen Leuten verhalten. Das heißt, wenn man Responsible Disclosure betreibt, läuft man eher in Gefahr, dass die Öffentlichkeit, die man ja zumindest als idealistischer Hacker informieren will, da möglicherweise sehr lange noch nichts davon erfährt.
Ja, oder gar nichts. Oder sehr eingeschränkt, je nachdem, wie stark man dann auch ist und sich halt eben einschüchtern lässt. Ja, also ich meine, Einschüchterung ist halt so ein echt krasses Thema bei sowas. Wenn man den Leuten im Vorfeld die Möglichkeit gibt, mit dir über deinen Bug zu sprechen, dann können die genauso gut versuchen, dich unter Druck zu setzen. Und wenn du diesem Druck nicht standhalten kannst, dann gehen da möglicherweise ein paar coole Details verloren in der Öffentlichkeit, die du eigentlich gerne auf deiner Kerbe erholst.
Da kommen dann so eine Bug-Beschreibung raus, wie irgendwie, hier ist ein Patch und der.
Softwarehersteller von denen wieder sagen würde, wenn ihr den Patch installiert, dann ist eure Garantie gelöst.
Der hat dann überhaupt keine Basis zu entscheiden, ob das ein Problem ist, das ihn betrifft oder nicht. Oder ob er vielleicht eine andere Möglichkeit hat, dieses Security-Problem in den Griff zu kriegen, indem er keine Ahnung nach einer Firewall davor klebt und nach bestimmten Mustern sucht oder sowas.
Okay, was mich jetzt auch interessieren würde, kurz vor den Nachrichten und bevor wir dann ausführlich dazu kommen, was jetzt so Hersteller machen können oder wie sie sich verhalten, ist, wir haben jetzt über Responsible und Full Disclosure gesprochen, d.h. da gehen wir bei beiden Fällen davon aus, dass jemand einen Fehler findet und dann langsam oder schnell die Öffentlichkeit informieren will. Jetzt ist es ja so, egal was der Mensch anfängt, es gibt immer Leute, die Geld machen wollen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man so einen Fehler findet, dass es dann auch einen Markt gibt für, ich verkaufe das an die bösen Jungs, die ja auch schon erwähnt haben. Also es gibt ja Leute, die haben Interesse daran, in das Thema anzugreifen.
Na klar, das ist immer die Option, dass man hingeht und guckt, wer dann am meisten für diesen Bug bietet. Da gibt es diverse Märkte dafür, das eine sind natürlich die üblichen Cyberkriminellen, also die Jungs, die Viren schreiben, die dann Spam verschicken oder dir die Tannen klauen, deine E-Banking stören oder was auch immer, dich erpressen mit der Tannis löschen.
Oder diese Staaten, die dann in dein Video-Conferencing-System eindringen und plötzlich ganz viele Zugriffsrechte haben.
Das ist der andere Markt. Also je nachdem, ob man einen einen oder anderen Markt verkaufen möchte, gibt es da auch verschiedene Broker dabei.
Aber es gibt einen Markt auf jeden Fall, und der ist nicht klein.
Ja, der ist nicht klein. Also ich meine, der Markt wurde ja erst dadurch realisiert, dass die ganzen Regierungen weltweit das auch legalisiert haben, dass eben so eine staatlich legitimierte Shard-Software zum Einsatz kommen darf.
Also da reden wir auch von richtig Geld, ja. So ein, zum Beispiel ein Exploit, mit dem man ein iPhone übernehmen kann, der geht auf dem Markt durchaus mal für 250.000 Euro weg. Also da überlegt man sich das möglicherweise schon dreimal, was man jetzt mit dem Wacken macht. Und den veröffentlicht er doch lieber.
Ob man sich mit dem Wendor rumschlägt und sich da einschüchtern lässt und NDAs unterschreiben muss, oder einen feuchten Händedruck bekommt, der fösentlichen, oder ob man das Ding einfach für 200k verkauft.
Ja, aber also aus der persönlichen Sicht klingt das so, dass es eigentlich also für die einzelne Person jetzt mal vom Idealismus und dem humanistischen Ideal abgesehen, die erfolgreichste Lösung wäre, das zu verkaufen. Oder ist das auch so ein Schattenmarkt, der auch sozusagen mit den üblichen Gefahren... Also ist es jetzt so, dass man sich vorstellen muss, man geht halt irgendwo hin, sagt hier so Zero Day Exploit, also Schadsoftware, die noch niemand kennt, außer ich. Ich verkaufte die, oder ist das dann eher so schattige Straßenecken, wo man auch mal abgestochen wird?
Ich habe jetzt keine Erfahrung mit dem russischen Markt, aber irgendwie so diese... Die Regierungskonnections sind eigentlich relativ sicher. Da bekommt man sein Geld, da wird man nicht abgestochen. Bei Russen bekommt man auch sein Geld, das ist nicht das Problem. Aber da kann man vielleicht einen falschen geraten, weiß ich nicht.
Habt ihr überhaupt eine Einschätzung drüber, wie die Verteilung ist in der Kreis der Leute, die sich damit beschäftigt? Gibt es da eine Tendenz irgendwohin? Also ist es eher so, dass man eigentlich lieber der idealistische Hacker ist, der das an die Öffentlichkeit bringt, oder gibt es tatsächlich diesen riesigen Schattenmarkt, der sowas macht?
Naja, der Sinn hinter diesem Markt ist, dass man das Ding für viel Geld verkauft und dann nicht mehr darüber spricht. Also wenn man nicht mehr darüber spricht, gibt es auch keine Zahlen.
Ja, natürlich. Ich gehe auch eher sozusagen von so einem Gefühl aus, weil wenn so eine Sicherheitslücken, die kommen irgendwann dann manchmal doch raus. Also bei Stuxnet hat man das ja gesehen. Der ist ja dieser Virus, der diese iranischen Atomeinreichungsanlagen anfallen sollte. Der wurde ja untersucht und dann wurde da festgestellt, es gibt die und die Sicherheitslücken, die kannten wir vorher aber noch gar nicht.
Da geht tatsächlich das Gerücht, dass die von Russen verkauft wurden, ja. Aber nichts Genaues weiß man nicht. Da gibt es keine Zahlen, da gibt es keine Mengenvorstellungen, völlig klar.
Es gibt es, aber man weiß nicht genau, wie viel. Wir machen jetzt das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und danach beschäftigen wir uns mal, wie es denn so ist, wenn man so eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden hat und dann zu so einer Firma geht, was da alles passieren kann. Also ab vom positivsten Fall, dass ihr alle drum kümmert, wenn alles schick ist. So, wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr danach dann auch anrufen und noch ein paar Fragen stellen. 0371 77 1 1 0 wäre die Nummer. Jetzt aber, wie gesagt, erstmal Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Lang wurden sie gesucht, jetzt stehen sie fest. Neun junge neue Bands und Künstler aus ganz Deutschland. Und am 8. September spielen sie alle live, um ihn zu gewinnen.
Der New Music Award.
Das Finale. Sonntag, 8. September im Admiraltspalast. Und ihr könnt vielleicht dabei sein. Denn Karten gibt's nirgendwo zu kaufen, sondern nur zu gewinnen. Klickt einfach fritz.de slash nma. Und natürlich übertragen wir das auch live im Radio.
Und das war's mal um kurz nach halb elf. Die 5 UN-Veto-Mächte USA, Großbritannien, Frankreich, Russland und China beraten jetzt am Abend nochmal über die Krise in Syrien. Grundlage ist ein britischer Resolutionsentwurf, der einen Militäreinsatz erlauben würde. Darin heißt es, es müssten alle notwendigen Maßnahmen zum Schutz von Zivilpersonen ergriffen werden. Experten der Vereinten Nationen untersuchen noch bis morgen, ob die syrische Regierung tatsächlich Giftgas gegen die Rebellen eingesetzt hat. Russland und China lehnen einen Militärschlag gegen die Truppen von Staatschef Assad ab. Die Landesregierung von Brandenburg hat den Belegungsstopp für die umstrittenen Hasenburg-Heime teilweise verlängert. Bildungsministerin Münch sagte, dass nur das Haus in Neuendorf ab Sonntag wieder neue Jugendliche aufnehmen darf. Für die Unterkunft in Münchenberg gilt der Belegungsstopp weiter. Das Heim in Jesern ist komplett stillgelegt. In den Hasenburg-Heimen sollen Jugendliche misshandelt worden sein. Eine Untersuchungskommission prüft gerade, ob die Vorwürfe stimmen. Bei den schweren Waldbränden in Portugal ist eine Feuerwehrfrau ums Leben gekommen. Fünf andere Feuerwehrleute wurden im Einsatz gegen die Flammen zum Teil schwer verletzt. Seit mehr als einer Woche brennen Wälder im Norden von Portugal. Insgesamt wurden bei den Löscharbeiten drei Feuerwehrleute getötet. Mehrere Dörfer mussten evakuiert werden. Fußball-Bundesliga ist Eintracht. Frankfurt hat die Gruppenphase der Europa League erreicht. Die Hessen gewannen das Playoff-Rückspiel gegen Karabach Agdam aus Aserbaidschan mit 2 zu 1. Das Hinspiel hatten die Frankfurter ebenfalls gewonnen. Der VfB Stuttgart dagegen hat den direkten Einzug in die Europa League verpasst. Die Schwaben kamen gegen Rijeka aus Kroatien nicht über ein 2 zu 2 hinaus und hatten das Hinspiel verloren. Stuttgart kann die Gruppenphase aber noch durch die Hintertür erreichen. Einer der Playoff-Verlierer wird morgen als Ersatz für den türkischen Vizemeister Fenerbahçe Istanbul ausgelost. Der Fußballspitzenclub aus der Türkei und der ukrainische Verein Metalist Rakow sind von der UEFA von dem Wettbewerb ausgeschlossen worden, weil sie verdächtigt werden, Spiele manipuliert zu haben. Temperaturen zwischen 14 und 19 Grad in Berlin und Brandenburg heute Abend wechseln sich klarer Himmel und Wolken ab, es bleibt meistens trocken. Heute Nacht ist es meist klar oder locker bewölkt und die Temperaturen gehen dann auf 14 bis 9 Grad runter. Morgen wird es schön sonnig mit nur ein paar Wolken zwischendurch und es bleibt trocken bei maximal 25 Grad. Berlin A100, der Stadtring Richtung Norden, bis 5 Uhr früh finden im Brizardtunnel in Neukölln Wartungsarbeiten statt, deshalb ist der Stadtring statt einwärts zwischen Buschkruge Allee und Oberlandstraße gesperrt. Treptow, die Kiefholzstraße, zwischen Baumschulenweg und Rixdorfer Straße ist nur eine Spur frei in beiden Richtungen. Zur U-Bahn, seit 22 Uhr bis Betriebsschluss fahren für die U3 zwischen Nollendorf und Färberliner Platz keine Züge, nur ersatzweise Busse. Und ein Hinweis für morgen früh Moabit, die Turmstraße wird zwischen Strom- und Waldstraße ab 6 Uhr früh bis einschließlich Sonntag wegen eines Straßenfestes in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Busse werden umgeleitet. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon und zu Gast sind Thorsten und Andreas. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal.
Guten Tag.
Und wir sprechen über Responsible und Full Disclosure. Und ich versuche noch mal kurz zusammenzufassen, was es ist. Und ihr müsst dann sagen, ob ich es richtig gemacht habe. Also es geht darum, dass ja Leute bei Computersystemen, Software oder manchmal auch Hardware eine Sicherheitslücke finden, die man ausnutzen kann, also die man nutzen kann, um das System kaputt zu machen oder möglicherweise auch zu übernehmen. Und die Frage ist, wie bringt man das an die Öffentlichkeit? Da gibt es zwei Strategien. Die eine ist, man sagt erst demjenigen, der diese Software vertreibt oder hergestellt hat, Bescheid, guck mal, du hast eine Sicherheitslücke und baut darauf, dass der das dann repariert. Und wenn das alles repariert ist, dann sagt man der Öffentlichkeit, guck mal, hier gibt es eine Sicherheitslücke. Das andere Full Disclosure ist, man geht sofort hin und sagt der Öffentlichkeit, guck mal, das ist total kaputt. Das hat alles Vor- und Nachteile. Die haben wir in der ersten halben Stunde erläutert und auch noch geklärt, dass es so einen Schattenmarkt gibt. Also dass es auch tatsächlich Leute gibt, die sowas dann einfach verkaufen, damit die bösen Jungs damit Rechner aufmachen können. Jetzt ist die Frage, wir haben ja schon darüber geredet, oder ihr habt es schon angedeutet, dass bei Responsible Disclosure, also wenn ich zu einem Hersteller gehe und sage, hier lieber Hersteller, ich habe eine Sicherheitslücke, tu was, dass der dann manchmal nicht so reagiert, wie man das will. Was man will, ist ja der Hersteller sagt, aha, sehr interessant, vielen Dank, dass du das gesagt hast, wir werden uns darum kümmern, das sofort wieder ganz zu machen. Also das ist ja das, was ich vor allen Dingen als Nutzer auch haben will, dass meine Systeme immer so ganz sind, wie es nur geht. Aber in der Realität scheint das ein bisschen anders zu sein. Was sind denn so typische Probleme, wenn ich jetzt hingehe, eine Sicherheitslücke habe und dem Hersteller sagen will, guck mal, da ist was kaputt.
Du wächst schlafende Hunde und die Anwälte.
Könnten wir das ein bisschen ausführlicher haben?
Ja, also es gibt also ein ganz nettes, na nett ist das nicht, aber es gibt ein schönes Beispiel, ich war gerade irgendwie auf der Eusenix Veranstaltung in Washington DC, das ist halt so eine akademische Veranstaltung, wo Forscher Papers submitten können, wo sie halt irgendwie ihren Security Research vorstellen und es gibt da Leute, die haben so ein Security Chip angegriffen, den Megamoss, also der wird verwendet zum Beispiel in der Kfz-Branche, um damit eben Wegfahrsperren zu implementieren und die haben im Grunde genommen eben diesen, also die haben halt an diesem Thema researched, also geforscht und haben am Ende Ergebnisse gehabt, die durchaus negativ für den Hersteller dieses Chips sind und dann haben sie dem Chip-Hersteller am Ende davon erzählt, dass es da ein Problem gibt mit ganz grundlegenden Dingen und was ist am Ende passiert. Sie haben ihre wissenschaftliche Arbeit geschrieben, haben das submitted an diese akademische Veranstaltung, das Paper wurde angenommen und am Ende hat der Hersteller dieses Chips erwirkt, dass das höchste Gericht in London die Veröffentlichung von technischen Details untersagt. Dann standen die Forscher quasi auf dieser wissenschaftlichen Veranstaltung und haben dann Vortrag gehalten, ohne technische Details zu nennen und am Ende dieses Paper zu releasen, was natürlich dann auch nachteilig ist für ihre Reputation, weil sie eben eine Veröffentlichung weniger haben.
Warum machen Hersteller das?
Weil das möglicherweise einfach echt viel Geld kostet, sowas dann auszutauschen und vielleicht auch einfach einen Reputationsverlust bedeutet, der eben irreparabel ist für den Hersteller. In dem Fall wäre das halt wirklich ein Hardware-Bug und man müsste im Grunde genommen ziemlich hohen Aufwand treiben, um das Ganze zu reparieren, weil ich meine, das betrifft dann wirklich so eine ganz grundlegende Einheit in so einer Fertigung von so einem Auto. Du musst dir halt vorstellen, so ein Chip wird halt nicht von BMW oder VW gekauft und in das Auto eingelötet. Du hast dann halt da auch Zwischenhändler, also einfach Zulieferer, die dann einfach Chips kaufen und mit diesen Chips Wegfahrsperren bauen. Und diese Wegfahrsperren werden dann an verschiedene Kfz-Hersteller verkauft. Und jetzt stell dir halt einfach vor, wie man diesen Bug beheben kann oder eben patchen kann, wenn man einen Bug in diesem Chip findet, der da irgendwo ganz oben in dieser Kette mal hergestellt wurde.
Aber trotzdem muss doch am Ende irgendwie ein genereller Konsens sein, dass solche Sachen möglichst sicher sein müssen. Oder bin ich dazu naiv?
Na ja, also ich glaube schon, dass große Firmen da manchmal ganz schön mit dem Rotstift rechnen, sich überlegen, was jetzt teurer ist, den Anwalt zu bezahlen, um einen armen Sicherheitsvorscher zu verklagen oder, keine Ahnung, 20 Millionen Autos aus deutscher Produktion zurückzurufen, da jeweils die Kies zu tauschen. Das hat teuer, kostet Geld.
Muss man halt, die wegen einen auch nur ab, das ist halt so, die machen doch auch nur dann am Ende eine Rechnung, was ist teurer am Ende.
Ja, aber ich würde tatsächlich vermuten, es ist immer teurer, so eine Sicherheitslücke zu verschweigen, weil wenn jetzt der Forscher sozusagen nicht veröffentlicht, dann findet sie halt der nächste irgendwann raus. Oder ist es so, dass ein Bug immer grundsätzlich nur von einem Menschen rausgefunden wird?
Nö, das kann ja gar keiner garantieren, dass nicht ein anderer den gleichen Bug auch findet. Ich meine, es gibt halt wie gesagt diesen Markt, von dem wir ja gerade, wo wir gerade festgestellt haben, dass wir gar nichts über diesen Markt wissen, also keine Zahlen. Wenn wir schon keine Zahlen haben, dann wissen wir auch nicht, was auf diesen Markt am Ende über den Ladentisch geht. Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass so ein Bug, wie das, was diese Forscher da gerade vorstellen wollten, schon seit zwei Jahren bekannt ist, aber eben auf dem Schwarzmarkt gehandelt wird, da wo eben meintetwegen Autos aufgemacht werden, möglichst ohne Spuren zu hinterlassen, um die Autos zu klauen und über eine Grenze zu schiffen. Also das kann ja durchaus sein.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen ein Extrem. Gibt es noch andere Strategien von Herstellern, wie sie so eine Sache entgehen zu versuchen, zu entgehen?
Also der Veröffentlichung von...
Genau, dass man ankommt und sie sagen, ja, nee, das wollen wir lieber nicht, geh mal weg, du bist doof.
Na ja, wie ich schon sagte, als Erstes werden sie halt versuchen, einen Druck aufzubauen auf den Researcher oder denjenigen, der diesen Fehler gefunden hat. Und je nachdem, wie stark der ist, das heißt, es ist zum Beispiel einfach eine Privatperson, irgendein unbedarfter Hacker, der jetzt auch endlich mal was gefunden hat. Oder ist das irgendeine Firma aus der Security-Industrie, die das schon gewohnt ist? Oder ist das halt irgendein Broker, der das täglich macht, irgendwelche schlechten Nachrichten zu überbringen? Also am Ende ist es halt auch ein Unterschied, ob man mit irgendeiner kleinen Web-App-Coder-Firma zu tun hat oder mit irgendeinem großen multinationalen Konzern, der halt auch entsprechend viel Geld zur Verfügung hat, dich in Grund und Boden zu klagen oder Mundtut zu machen. Also ich meine, diese Researcher, die diese Sachen mit dem Mega-Moster aufgedeckt haben, die haben auch eine ähnliche Sache zum Beispiel gefunden. Die haben halt irgendwie im NXP, im Myfair-Chips irgendwelche Bugs gefunden und die haben da genauso auch die Auflage bekommen, dass sie nicht darüber reden dürfen.
Was sind das für Chips?
Na, so RFID-Chips für Zutrittssysteme zum Beispiel verwendet werden, zur Authentifizierung.
Also quasi, wenn man hier so eine Tür hat, wo man so eine Chipkarte vorhält, dann geht die Tür auf.
Genau, und die haben den quasi per einswürdiger Verfügung, oder was auch immer das da war, haben denen das quasi verboten, die technischen Details dazu zu veröffentlichen. Und die haben insgesamt sechs Monate lang da weitergeklagt, bis am Ende das Gericht gesagt hat, nö, ihr könnt das schon veröffentlichen. Aber es braucht halt einfach einen langen Atem. Und da muss man einfach erst mal die Kraft und auch die finanziellen Mittel zu haben. Also so ein Risiko auch einzugehen, das ist halt einfach.
Aber gibt es da nicht auch sozusagen eine Gegenbewegung? Weil kann man nicht irgendwann die Firmen verklagen und sagen, ihr wusstet doch die ganze Zeit, dass es da Sicherheitslücken gibt. Wieso habt ihr das nicht gesagt? Und vor allem, warum habt ihr das nicht wieder ganz gemacht?
Wie willst du die verklagen, wenn du gar nicht über die Details sprechen darfst?
Nee, als Kunde. Also gesetzlichen Fall, das kommt uns...
Hast du schon mal Produkthaftung bei Software gesehen?
Nein, deswegen frage ich euch ja her, komm doch mal.
Nee, also kannst du nicht.
Weil? Was ist das mit dieser Produkthaftung bei Software?
Na, das steht im Wesentlichen drin in den Lizenzverträgen, dass dir die Firma nicht garantiert, dass diese Software irgendwas kann. Und dass, wenn sie das nicht kann, was du denkst, dass sie es kann, dann dafür auch nicht haftet. Insbesondere nicht, wenn sie Dinge nicht tut.
Aha, also die meisten Software, die ich kaufe, da kaufe ich sozusagen, also im Prinzip nur einen wilden Haufen Code. Wenn ich Glück habe, funktioniert das. Aber so ein Recht habe ich dazu nicht. Okay, da sind doch keine Juristen auf die Idee gekommen, dass mal...
Du bist doch bloß Verbraucher, was willst du?
Entschuldigung, ich möchte funktionieren, da wird vor allen Dingen sichere Software. Aber das heißt, so eine Hersteller holen dann immer die juristische Keule raus, oder gibt es auch noch andere Wege?
Nö, nicht immer. Na ja, was heißt denn... Na gut, ich meine, was haben die sonst in der Hand als irgendwie Juristen?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Also klar, vielleicht gibt es auch Firmen, die dann irgendein Killer-Kommando auf dich lossetzen, aber das ist glaube ich eher die Seltenheit. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so ist.
Wie bringt man denn eine Firma dazu, trotzdem damit in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen? Oder was sind Kompromisse, auf die man sich einlassen kann?
Wie meinst du das jetzt, also wo die, meinst du jetzt den Hersteller der Software, dass man denen irgendwie klarmacht, dass sie da auch Vorteile von haben, wenn sie auf dieses Prozede reingehen? Sie können zumindest demonstrieren, dass sie Verantwortung übernehmen und verantwortungsvoll mit solchen Problemen umgehen und sich fair verhalten und damit mit diesem Verhalten ja dann auch andere Leute motivieren, Bugs zu submitten. Weil ich meine, das ist dann for free. Normalerweise müssen so eine Firmen ja Leute beauftragen, die Software zu reviewn, die dann möglicherweise diese Schwachstellen schon vorher vor der Veröffentlichung finden. Aber im Grunde genommen, ja, ich meine die meisten Firmen, die auch schon viel mit Bugs zu tun hatten, wie Microsoft, Adobe und all die anderen großen Firmen, die sind auch entsprechend professionell. Die wissen, wie man damit umgeht. Ja, die lassen sich dann halt auch nicht auf jeden Mist ein. Die sagen halt so, okay, wir gucken uns das an. Und wenn die damit nicht einverstanden sind, dann sagen die halt nö. Aber die gehen halt professionell mit um. Die sagen, alles klar, wir haben hier irgendwie eine Deadline, 45 Tage, alles klar, dann haben wir einen Patch draußen. Anschließend veröffentlichen wir selber eine Warnung, geben dann auch noch die Credits entsprechend weiter. Also dein Name wird dann auch noch von dem Softwarehersteller mit veröffentlicht. Und das ist halt so das Mindeste, dass man diese Credits bekommt. Weil das ist im Grunde genommen eben das, was Andreas ja auch sagte. Wenn du mal dich irgendwo bewirbst, dann kannst du sagen, da, da und da, das sind die Bugs, die ich mal gefunden habe. Und Leute, die Ahnung haben von Bugs, die können halt auch sagen, das war schwierig zu finden oder schwierig zu exploiten. Oder eben nicht.
Okay, also das ist aber zu sagen, dass man dem Hersteller, den den Vorgang lässt, also dass er das sozusagen an die Öffentlichkeit bringen darf. Das ist schon okay, solange er das...
Er hat halt die Kontrolle auch noch ein Stück weit. Also anders als beim Full Disclosure, wo der Hersteller ja erst davon mitkriegt, wenn es schon öffentlich ist, kann ein Hersteller natürlich halt den Kontakt zu demjenigen, der es gefunden hat und kann auch sagen so, hey, hör mal, wir geben uns ja Mühe, das in 45 Tagen zu patchen, aber das ist ein Problem, das zieht halt einen Rattenschwanz an Abhängigkeiten mit sich und wir brauchen noch 30 Tage mehr.
Das ist dann schon okay, wenn man sich da als Sicherheitsforscher hinschaut.
Also kann man sich halt einfach in Dialog begeben, solange das alles fair bleibt, ist das doch super für alle Parteien. Also ich meine, hat doch jeder was davon. Der Softwarehersteller hat halt genug Zeit, sein Problem zu beheben, die Benutzer rechtzeitig zu warnen und dann...
Gibt es denn da jetzt so weiße und schwarze Schafe, die jetzt vor allen Dingen für eine größere Öffentlichkeit relevant sind, wo man so Geschichten kennt?
Also Microsoft ist glaube ich ein Beispiel für einen Hersteller, der die Lektionen sehr schmerzhaft gelernt, aber mittlerweile gut verinnerlicht hat. Da war es vor zehn Jahren noch so, dass die im Prinzip überhaupt gar nicht sich dafür interessiert haben, wenn irgendjemand irgendein Securityproblem hatte, was dann dazu geführt hat, dass sie wirklich massiv unter Druck gesetzt wurden mit Full Disclosure-Veröffentlichungen, einem nach dem anderen, bis es Bill Gates irgendwann gereicht hat, die gesagt hat, jetzt machen wir einen Monat in der ganzen Firma nichts anderes außer Sicherheitsprobleme fixen. Und die haben dann auch eine eigene Abteilung dafür aufgesetzt. Also wenn man heutzutage so ein Sicherheitsproblem hat, schreibt man an secureatmicrosoft.com und wird da wirklich professionell betreut. Da ist dann also in der Regel, wenn es kein zu komplexes Problem ist, dann ist zum nächsten Patch Tuesday der Patch draußen, der das Problem löst.
Ok, ein Positivbeispiel, was haben wir denn noch so an großen Herstellern? Apple natürlich? Weiß man darüber was?
Ja, also ich würde behaupten, die sind irgendwie auch auf dem richtigen Weg, aber noch lange nicht da, wo Microsoft jetzt ist. Also was eben diesen ganzen Zyklus angeht. Da kommt mal ein Bugreport ein, wie gehe ich jetzt ordentlich damit um. Also es wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern, bis die auch auf dem Stand sind. Also was die Professionalität angeht und so weiter. Ich glaube, die haben auch noch mit einer größeren Menge an Bugs zu kämpfen. Die müssen halt auch dann einfach unterscheiden, was ist. Also die müssen halt irgendwie abwägen, was hat Security Impact. Also was kann halt wirklich problematisch werden für die Sicherheit aller Rechner und so. Oder halt einfach ein Usability Bug, das halt irgendwas einfach nur crasht. Es gibt ja viele Ursachen für so einen Crash. Und die meisten sind wahrscheinlich gar nicht exploitbar, sondern einfach nur doofe Programmierfehler oder Fehler.
Also aus dem man keinen Nutzen ziehen kann.
Genau, man kann halt die Software im Endeffekt abschießen und das war's. Und das kann halt auch durchaus sein, dass eben, es gab halt gerade eine entsprechende Veröffentlichung dazu von jemandem, der halt seit sechs Monaten versucht, da so einen Bug bei Apple unterzubringen. Der hat halt berichtet, ja hier, wenn ich die und die Zeichenkette da und da so formatiere und wenn man dann da draufklickt oder wenn ich das als SMS schicke oder als Wireless LAN SSID verwende, dann crasht halt irgendwie die entsprechende Software oder das Device, also iOS oder eben auf OSX so ein Browser.
Warte mal, wenn ich meinem WLAN einen bestimmten Namen gebe, dann alle, die danach suchen, also die sagen sich gerade mal alle WLANs anzeigen lassen, die stürzen dann einfach ab.
Ja, also ich hab das, weil es halt sehr frisch ist, ich hab das im Detail nicht angeguckt, aber was ich da gelesen habe, ist halt wirklich so, so eine SSID wird ja gebroadcastet und dein Device empfängt das ja, egal ob du das jetzt willst oder nicht. Ach so. Und wenn dein Device das einmal in der Liste hat und angezeigt wird, also das geht da halt um einen Bug, wo halt irgendwie auch wieder Schriften gerendert werden und das sorgt wohl angeblich dafür, dass dein iOS-Device dann rebooted und wenn es wieder hochgefahren ist, dann hat das natürlich diese Zeichenkette immer noch in der Liste der bekannten WLANs und egal ob du immer in der Nähe bist oder nicht, wird das halt irgendwie auch zu einem Crash führen. Also der Typ, der das gefunden hat, der dachte, das wäre was ganz anderes, der dachte, das wäre ein Webkit-Bug gewesen und hatte das irgendwie als Webkit-Bug bei Apple eingegossen und die haben sich dann sechs Monate nicht gemeldet.
Webkit, muss man wiederum erklären, ist sozusagen die Software, die hinter dem Browser liegt, also die für die Darstellung von Webseiten.
Also alles, was irgendwie Web-Content darstellt. Das ist nicht nur ein Webbrowser, sondern halt auch irgendein Gadget hier und da und also ja und dann hat sich Apple sechs Monate nicht gemeldet und hat gesagt, ach wisst ihr, dann veröffentliche ich das jetzt halt und ja, mittlerweile hat sich herausgestellt, dass es eben nicht nur ein Webkit-Bug ist, sondern irgendwie Core Text, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Das ist halt so ein Framework eben zum Rennern von irgendwelchen Schriften.
Also sagen, das ist so tief im Betriebssystem drin, dass es überall funktioniert, wo Schriften angezeigt werden?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Okay, das ist also Beispiel für eine Firma, die noch lernen muss anscheinend.
Ja, und ich meine, im Moment kann man halt dafür sorgen, dass das halt crasht. Das heißt, es gibt immer noch keinen Beweis, dass man da auch eine Code Execution hinbekommt.
Es gibt doch keinen Beweis des Gegenteils.
Genau, weil man kann halt höchstens beweisen, dass eine Code Execution möglich ist.
Code Execution ist dieses, man kann noch ein eigenes Programm ausführen, nachdem man ein anderes zum Absturz bringt.
Es stürzt nicht nur ab, sondern der böse Hacker kann auch seine eigene Software über diese Lücke reinschieben.
Schadhaften Code ausführen.
Ob das geht oder nicht, weiß man an dieser Stelle noch nicht. Aber gibt es denn sozusagen auch so Firmen in der Größe und der Relevanz für die Öffentlichkeit, die breitere, die so wirklich einen ganz schlechten Ruf haben? Also schwarze Schafe in der Security-Branche? Also nicht in der Security-Branche, sondern die halt, wo man schon weiß, die reagieren eigentlich nie auf irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken?
Hatte ich PHP schon erwähnt?
Ich habe gehört, dass es in der Open-Source-Community so Fälle gibt.
Aber das ist doch eigentlich seltsam, dass es die Open-Source-Community ist. Also Open-Source ist da der Gedanke dahinten, der Programmcode ist für jeden zugänglich, damit Fehler leichter gefunden werden können.
Ja, aber ich meine, was liest du dir den Quellcode durch von den Sachen, die du auf dem Internet hast?
Nein, nein, nein, aber es ist ja darauf, ich natürlich nicht, aber ich gehe davon aus, wenn das jemand findet, dann ist es natürlich auch von Interesse für die Leute, die es programmiert haben, weil die machen ja extra Open-Source, damit die Fehler leichter gefunden werden. Aber das scheint nicht...
Nein, nein, ich glaube, die Leute machen nicht extra Open-Source, damit die Fehler leichter gefunden werden, sondern weil sie einfach sagen, oh, ich bin jetzt Programmierer und guck, ich zeige euch, dass ich jetzt Programmierer bin und ich programmiere Sachen und ihr müsst sie benutzen. Keine Ahnung, also es gibt verschiedene Motivationen, warum man seinen Source der Öffentlichkeit...
Aber trotzdem war das jetzt das einzige Beispiel, wo ihr sagt, ja die haben eher einen schlechten Ruf, was den Umgang mit Fehlern angeht.
Ja, also, aber ich meine, schließt es das jetzt aus? Also ich meine, nur weil etwas Open Source ist, muss es nicht unbedingt besser sein. Oder eben der Umgang mit Bugs.
Nee, aber so sagen, ihr habt kein Beispiel für eine andere große Firma. Da scheint es eher zu laufen oder scheint mit ihr das Problem zum Klaren zu sein.
Ja, das mit Whatsapp, ich habe es gerade gelesen, also.
Cisco ist auch so ein Beispiel, da gab es auch Bugs, die sie zwölf Monate nicht gefixt haben, wo dann der Finder des Bugs sich genötigt sah, doch mal auf einer Konferenz drüber zu reden, weil die es einfach nicht hinbekommen haben. Die waren in dem Fall schlicht unfähig, die haben das Problem nicht verstanden.
Oder sie haben so getan.
Nee, in dem Fall irgendwie war es glaube ich tatsächlich.
Weil ihr gerade Whatsapp gesagt habt, das ist ja so ein Punkt, ist man da als sicherheitsbewusster Forscher manchmal auch ein bisschen hilflos. Weil das ist ja ein Punkt, wo man eigentlich denken müsste, okay, wenn es der Hersteller nicht fixt, dann müsste er wenigstens die Öffentlichkeit mal aufschreiten. Da geht es schließlich um ihre private Kommunikation, aber es interessiert ja keinen. Ist das sozusagen auch so ein Mittel, mit dem Firmen dann auch spielen, dass sie sagen, ja, macht doch ein Lautnis, uns doch egal, interessiert doch eh keinen. Also gibt es bestimmte Fehlerklassen, mit denen man mehr Druck ausüben kann als andere?
Ja klar, je größer das Problem ist, desto mehr Feedback bekommt man da. Also wenn ich einen Bug finde, wo ich sozusagen von außen mit einem einzigen Netzwerkpaket sofort admin werde auf einem Windows-System, dann ist das natürlich was völlig anderes als, sagen wir mal, eine Local Privilege Escalation oder etwas, wo ich irgendwie eingelogter Benutzer sein muss und dann unter bestimmten Umständen möglicherweise Denial-of-Service ausführen kann. Also da gibt es schon Unterschiede.
Ja, aber was ich meine, ist sozusagen, um es mal konkret zu fragen, ob jetzt ein Bug, der das Abhören von Informationen ermöglicht, ob der mit dem nicht so viel Druck ausüben kann, weil das eine Öffentlichkeit nicht so sehr interessiert, wie ich mache da irgendwas kaputt.
Na wahrscheinlich interessiert die Öffentlichkeit das erst, genau dann, wenn es irgendeinen Wurm gibt, der das Ganze automatisch ausnutzt, ohne dass irgendjemand den Finger krumm macht und das Ganze irgendwo eben veröffentlicht oder an irgendwelche Marketingfirmen verkauft. Wer weiß, es muss halt immer irgendwas passieren, in den meisten Fällen, wenn es eben um so populäre Sachen geht, wo die Leute auch wenig Bewusstsein für Privatsphäre und Sicherheit haben. Das kann durchaus sein.
Also je länger wir drüber sprechen, desto mehr kommst du so vor, als ob das Leben als Sicherheitsforscher nicht so einfach ist, weil die Firmen einfach größer und dicker sind.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Okay, da können wir gleich vielleicht nochmal über eine politische Dimension sprechen, eine politisch-rechtliche, es gibt irgendetwas mit, steht hier in der Vorbereitung, drohende Exportregulierung von Exploits, was verbirgt sich dahinter? Also gibt es da irgendwie die politischen, politische, ja Gott, Fortfindungsstörungen heute aber extrem. Gibt es ein politisches Bedürfnis, sowas zu unterbinden, so Sicherheitsforschung?
Unterbinden sicherlich nicht. Die Veröffentlichung vielleicht möglicherweise ja. Also das mit dieser Exportregulierung, das steht da halt vor allen Dingen deshalb, weil eine Veröffentlichung einer Schwachstelle oder vielleicht auch eines Proof of Concept Exploits, je nachdem wie irgendein Richter oder Staatsanwalt das auslegt, der durchaus auch einen Export darstellen kann, weil ich ja zum Beispiel, wenn ich es auf irgendein Web-Server lade, nicht verhindern kann, dass sich das jemand aus irgendwelchen Staaten runterlädt, die diesen Regulatorien unterliegen. Es gibt ja da ganz krude Bestrebungen seitens der Politiker, gerade in der EU, um zum Beispiel – da muss man gleich noch ein bisschen ausholen – es gab diese ganze Staatstrojanernummer vor ein paar Jahren und dann gab es ja ganz viel Wind um diese Firmen, die diese Staaten oder Beliefern mit Exploits und Frameworks, die sie eben für so eine Trojanernummer nehmen können, und diesen Firmen wollte man vielleicht am Ende einfach eins reinwürgen und sagen, ja, wir wollen einfach nur sicherstellen, dass diese Firmen, die ja vielleicht aus EU-Staaten operieren, eben nichts an irgendwelche Schurkenstaaten liefern dürfen. Und deswegen, vielleicht auch mit einer wirklich gut gemeinten Idee dahinter, hatte man dann eben versucht, da irgendwie Exportregulierung zu betreiben für Software, Waffen. Ja, man kann so ein Exploit auch durchaus als Waffe deklarieren, das ist halt was Politiker gerne mal tun. Und naja, dann ist das am Ende irgendwann schwammig und eine Auslegungssache. Also ich befürchte halt sehr stark, dass so eine Exportregulierung für Software exploits. Also eigentlich ist das nur ein Proof of Concept, der der Öffentlichkeit zeigen soll, ihr habt ein Problem und macht mal ein bisschen Druck auf den Softwarehersteller. Das kann halt durchaus ausgelegt werden als scharfe Waffe. Und dann wird derjenige, der das veröffentlicht hat, möglicherweise Ziel von irgendwelchen Ermittlungen, weil er irgendwie gegen diese Regulatorien verstoßen hat.
Also sagen, das ist nicht die grundlegende Idee des Gesetzes gewesen, aber das ist jetzt so schwammig, dass es möglicherweise passieren könnte.
Das führt am Ende dazu, dass wir wieder noch ein genauso schwammiges Gesetz kriegen, wie den Paragraph 202c, das STGB, also diesen sogenannten Hackerparagraphen, wo am Ende wieder keiner so genau weiß, mache ich mich jetzt ein Gestrafbar oder nicht, kann ich jetzt irgendwie von irgendwelchen US-Drohnen abgeschossen werden, ist das dann alles rechtlich einwandfrei oder eventuell nicht? Ja, also im Grunde genommen wird die Szene dadurch auch wieder verunsichert und am Ende führt es auch wieder dazu, dass die Leute anfangen, das Ganze einfach überhaupt nicht zu veröffentlichen, sondern zu verkaufen, weil das ist schön anonym und dann spricht keiner mehr drüber und fertig.
Da bewegen wir uns auf ein düsteres Pflaster. Jetzt haben wir den theoretischen Hintergrund geklärt. In der ersten Stunde des Chaosradio hier im Blue Moon. Wir wollen dann mal ein bisschen zu den Geschichtchen kommen, also den kleinen Anekdoten über Sicherheitsprobleme und den Umgang der Firmen damit. Falls ihr solche Geschichten auch kennt oder falls ihr jetzt noch Fragen habt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir hören eine kleine Musik von We Were Birds Just For You und dann sind wir wieder für heute. Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon mit Markus Richter und zu Gast sind Andreas und Thorsten vom CCC. Das ist alles noch ein bisschen verzögert hier. Kleine Sicherheitslücken. Wir reden auf jeden Fall heute über Probleme, die Computer und Software so haben können. Und zwar nicht über die Probleme konkret, sondern den Umgang damit. Das heißt, irgendjemand findet eine Sicherheitslücke und will dem Hersteller dann sagen, du, bei dir ist was kaputt und dann reden wir darüber, was da passieren kann. Es geht um Disclosure, also das an die Öffentlichkeit bringen. Und es gibt davon zwei Basistypen, wie man es machen kann. Nämlich einerseits zum Hersteller gehen, andererseits gleich direkt an die Öffentlichkeit. Und das mit dem an den... Oh Gott, was ist denn heute los? Ihr macht mich ganz nervös. Vielleicht weil ihr so viel tippt und mir gar nicht zuhört. Man geht also direkt zum Hersteller oder man geht direkt an die Öffentlichkeit. Und was dann passieren kann, das wollen wir jetzt so anekdotenhaft noch ein bisschen erzählen. Und Thorsten hat auch noch ein paar Geschichten mitgebracht. Bevor er aber anfängt, haben wir noch jemand am Telefon. Nämlich den Nexus auch vom CCC auf Hannover. Hallo und guten Abend. So, es gibt ja, wo wir auch gerade von WhatsApp sprachen, jetzt seit NSA und GHGQ und überhaupt die ganzen Überwachungssachen, ist ja das Bedürfnis zumindest gefühlt ein bisschen gestiegen aus sicherer Kommunikation und einer dieser Dienste, die einen so einen WhatsApp-ähnlichen Smartphone Messenger an den Start bringen wollten war Whistle.I.Am. Und mit denen hast du dich beschäftigt. Die haben ja gesagt, so, hier Messenger funktioniert nicht nur am Smartphone, sondern auch im Web und dann hast du einen Artikel geschrieben, wo drin stand, naja, das funktioniert nicht ganz so. Was war das Problem da?
Ja, erstmal verspricht der Hersteller da an der Stelle eine super sichere Kommunikation. Wenn man anfängt mit Whistle.am zu kommunizieren, dann wurde einem verkauft, dass danach, naja, über sichere Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, die dann auch groß auf der Webseite aufgeführt wurden, die Kommunikation abgesichert sein soll, Ende zu Ende. Und nachdem man da so ein bisschen einen Blick drauf geworfen hat, hat man eigentlich relativ schnell festgestellt, irgendwas stimmt an diesem Konzept nicht. Also der erste Punkt war, dass ich mir so ein bisschen die Webseite angeguckt habe. Ein Bekannter hatte das irgendwo verlinkt und meinte, das wäre ja ein spannendes Projekt. Und dann habe ich auf diese Webseite geguckt, da diese schöne Grafik gefunden, wo sie zeigen, wie sie das alles verschlüsseln. Und mein erstes Problem war, dass ich die eigentlich überhaupt nicht verstanden habe. Und man konnte eigentlich da schon relativ gut sehen, dass da irgendwie nicht so ganz verstanden wurde, was das auf die Hersteller ist, was wir selber nicht ganz verstanden haben, was sie da tun.
Jetzt hast du das sozusagen auch noch weiter ausgearbeitet und auch ein bisschen die Kommunikation dieser Software angeguckt und hast dich dann für die, wie wir es dir vorgestellt haben, Full Disclosure entschieden. Also du bist sofort an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen, hast nicht erst mit den Leuten gesprochen. Warum hast du dich dafür entschieden?
Einerseits war das ein bisschen ein Unfall. Also ich hatte gar nicht vor, das so aufzuhängen, dass das so eingeschlagen ist. Damit hatte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet. Andererseits war es so, dass ich mir diese Software angeguckt habe, habe dann entschieden, ja, guckst du dir jetzt mal an, was da so über die Leitung geht, habe mir das auf einem Handy installiert und habe dann einfach mal die Pakete, die da so unterwegs waren, mitgelesen und habe relativ schnell gesehen, das sieht ein bisschen komisch aus, das musst du dir mal genauer angucken. Habe mich dann dazwischen gehängt und habe dann relativ schnell festgestellt, dass an dieser Software so viel kaputt ist, dass man da eigentlich gar nicht mehr anfangen braucht zu flicken. Also von einem Bug möchte ich da an der Stelle schon gar nicht mehr reden. Und der Punkt ist, dass da natürlich auch die Benutzer sofort betroffen sind. Was wird davon geredet? Ja, wir haben hier eine super sichere Kommunikation. Wenn ich jetzt, ihr habt es vorhin angesprochen, wenn ich jetzt da hingehe und sage, ja, ihr habt jetzt zwei Wochen Zeit da was zu machen und dann schickt mal einen Patch oder so, ist das natürlich ein Punkt, das ist, wenn es um persönliche Kommunikation geht, wenn es darum geht, Kommunikation abzusichern und sich auf der anderen Seite herausstellt, dass diese ganze Kommunikation so offen ist, dass da grundsätzlich mit ein bisschen Sachverstand jeder mitlesen kann, dann stellt sich da die Frage, warum, was man da auch erwarten soll, was ein solcher Hersteller dann an Verbesserungen mitbringt.
Also die Lücke war so ernsthaft und konzeptuell so kaputt, dass du gesagt hast, da dürfen wir keine Zeit verlieren, das soll dann auch, wenn es an die Öffentlichkeit kommt, Broken by Design.
Also genau, Broken by Design ist ein Punkt. Anderer Punkt ist natürlich, dass sich Leute darauf verlassen, dass das sicher ist. Der nächste Punkt ist, dass da ein großes Marketing drumrum lief. Sie sind halt in mehreren Zeitungen gewesen, also auch so eher consumerorientierte Blätter wie Computerbild oder sonst irgendwas haben darüber berichtet und auch sehr positiv darüber berichtet. Man muss natürlich dann auch in dem Moment damit rechnen, dass jetzt Benutzer anfangen, auf diesen Zug aufzuspringen. Genau wie das bei WhatsApp ist, da ist darüber diskutiert worden, ja, das ist alles unsicher, am besten sollten wir das alles lassen, aber meine ganzen Freunde sind da. Wenn man erst mal an diesen Punkt angekommen ist, und das kann sich innerhalb von ein, zwei Monaten ganz zügig ändern, dann ist es einfach zu spät.
Ja, also ich meine, das Ding, was er eben anspricht, ist meiner Meinung nach einfach Fahrlässigkeit, weil denen der Öffentlichkeit einfach suggeriert wird, ja, wir haben hier Probleme mit Überwachung durch Staat und irgendwelche anderen Organisationen, also brauchen wir verschlüsselte Systeme, um zu kommunizieren, und wir haben da mal was gebaut. Und am Ende sind die Benutzer, die klicken dann auf genau das, was am breitesten in den Medien und in der Öffentlichkeit bereitgetreten wird, weil die gar nicht einschätzen können, was da eigentlich technisch dahinter steckt. Und man kann da so viel falsch machen. Ich bin halt einfach der Meinung, wenn man davon keine Ahnung hat, sollte man eben die Finger davon lassen und auch eben nicht so agieren. Das ist eben einfach fahrlässig. Gerade wenn dann eben diese ganzen tollen Crypto-Partys stattfinden, die ja an sich gut sind, aber manchmal kann man halt einfach auch nicht einschätzen, was steckt eigentlich technisch im Detail hinter dem, was ich da jetzt empfehle zur Absicherung der Kommunikation. Weil vielleicht am Ende irgendwelche Journalisten oder politisch aktiven Menschen in irgendwelchen Regionen mit dieser Software am Ende arbeiten und am Ende ihr Leben riskieren, weil das System vielleicht doch nicht so sicher ist. Vor diesem Whistle-EM gab es ja irgendwie diese Crypto-Cat-Nummer, wo zum Beispiel der Programmierer, der das initiiert hat, einfach mal ganz anders umgegangen ist mit den Problemen, nachdem das veröffentlicht wurde. Ich will das jetzt nicht vorgreifen, aber ich möchte jetzt einfach noch mal zurückkommen zu diesem Whistle-EM, weil sich das schon sehr stark unterscheidet. Wie reagieren die Hersteller am Ende auf so eine Anschuldigung?
Das würde ich jetzt gerade erstmal den Nexus fragen wollen. Das hatten wir noch gar nicht.
Bevor du jetzt mit der nächsten Frage kommst, ich gehe da jetzt nochmal kurz zwischen. So eine Sache, die mir auch sehr aufgefallen ist, ist diese aggressive Werbung. Man merkt, es sind zwei Studenten, die das entwickelt haben. Man merkt, dass auf das Marketing extrem viel Wert gelegt wurde. Also diese ganze Webseite ist sehr shiny hochgezogen worden und es sah alles sehr toll aus. Und im Text wird beschrieben, dass da auch der Informant dann mit der Presse kommunizieren kann sicher und dass die Idee dahinter ist. Und das ist natürlich ein Punkt, da möchte ich auch nicht mehr davon reden, dass dir jetzt irgendwas vermittelt wird oder dass da was falsch verstanden wird oder dass es nur gefährlich ist, sondern da möchte ich eigentlich an den Punkt kommen, dass das eigentlich schon, ich würde sagen, verarschend von Benutzern ist. Nee, Vorsatz würde ich da nicht unterstellen, das kann ich so nicht. Also ich gehe eher davon aus, dass sie überhaupt nicht wissen, wovon sie reden oder nicht verstehen, wie diese Systeme funktionieren, den technischen Hintergrund nicht haben und dann so etwas aufziehen. Und wenn du jetzt zu der Frage mit dem Umgang kommen möchtest, dann zeigt sich eigentlich, dass das auch der richtige Ansatz war mit dem Full Disclosure.
Ja, das wäre jetzt genau meine nächste Frage. Also wie haben die denn reagiert? Weil das war ja sozusagen für einen Hersteller die schlimmste mögliche Nachricht, die man bekommen kann. Oh mein Gott, das ist alles kaputt.
Also die Sache war, es ist halt irgendwie so übers Internet geleakt. Ich habe das halt abends mal ins Internet gestellt, eigentlich hier so für ein paar Bekannte, die mich darum gebeten hatten, das mal aufzuschreiben. Und morgens habe ich dann mal ein Notebook aufgeklappt und hatte irgendwie knapp 40 neue Mails, wo mir alle möglichen Leute geschrieben haben, ja, das wäre ja total gut und ob ich nicht Alternativen hätte. Darunter war dann auch eine Mail von den Anbietern, das war ja schon mal ganz nett, dass sie sich bei mir gemeldet haben, wo sie mir dann eine Liste von technischen Fragen vorgeworfen haben, wo sie dann von mir mal so eine Bewertung haben wollten, wie sie es denn besser machen können. Also quasi noch Ideen, wie man jetzt damit umgehen könnte.
Willst du uns nicht unser Protokoll neu designen für lau?
Ja genau, genau. Also so ist es irgendwie gewesen. Sie schreiben auf der Webseite, dass die Kryptographie Open Source ist. Als ich das erste Mal da drauf geguckt habe, dachte ich jetzt, oh toll, eine neue Open Source App. Kann ich mal reingucken, wie die so aussieht, und mir dann überlegen, ob das das ist. Musste dann feststellen, dass das zwei JavaScript-Sites, die da offen sind, und da sind die Krypto-Algorithmen drin. Aber da wird auch suggeriert, das ist alles Open Source. Nein, die Teile, die ich auseinandergepflückt habe, sind eben die Teile, die nicht Open Source sind. Das ist tatsächlich die Kommunikation mit dem Server. Aber um zur ursprünglichen Frage zurückzukommen, ich habe dann auf diese Mail geantwortet, was wahrscheinlich im Nachhinein auch ein bisschen ein Fehler war, habe ihnen dann noch zwei, drei neue Sachen gesagt, die mir auch aufgefallen sind, die auch ein Problem sind, die ich gar nicht veröffentlicht habe. Woraufhin sie dann durch die Presse gelaufen sind und erzählt haben, dass sie mit dem Hacker, der das alles aufgedeckt haben, in Kontakt stehen, was so auch nicht stimmt. Ich habe seitdem nie wieder was von denen gehört. Sie sind auch durch die Gegend gelaufen und haben gesagt, dass mit dem kaputten Random Number Generator, also dem Zufallszahlen Generator, das wussten sie auch schon alles. Das habe ich ihnen nämlich mitgeteilt in meiner Mail. Und naja, der andere Punkt ist, sie haben bis heute ihre Benutzer nicht darüber informiert, dass es da ein Problem gab und dass eigentlich alle Nachrichten, die über dieses System ausgetauscht wurden, niemals sicher ausgetauscht wurden. Auch in dieser Zwischenphase, wo sie an dem Patch gearbeitet haben, um genau diese Sachen, also tatsächlich so ein, naja, wir haben jetzt hier so ein paar Punkte, die lösen wir mal, dann geht das alles schon wieder. In dieser Zwischenzeit, das wurde gefunden, und sie haben eine neue Version nach drei Tagen, haben sie nicht ihre Benutzer darüber informiert, dass da ein Problem vorliegt, obwohl sie das wissentlich, also sie wussten es, dass das so ist. Das wäre für mich vielleicht ein Punkt gewesen, wo ich hätte sagen müssen, ich muss die Server ausschalten. Vielleicht kommuniziert da jetzt jemand sicher, oder denkt, er ist jetzt sicher, und jemand anderes liest das mit.
Ist die Software jetzt deiner Einschätzung nach jetzt sicher, oder?
Naja, ich habe sie mir nicht noch mal angeguckt, aber diese Punkte, die ich gefunden habe, das sind grundlegende Punkte gewesen, das ist etwas, wo nicht mal ein Krypto-Anfänger darüber stolpern sollte. Ich möchte mir nicht ausmalen, wenn man tiefer in die Software guckt, was da los ist. Also den Schritt, den habe ich gar nicht mehr gemacht. Das war an der Stelle so grottig und so grausam, was sich da aufgetan hat. Also ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet, dass ich in meinem Leben noch mal so was sehe.
Also von deiner Seite aus ist das ein Beispiel dafür, dass sowohl die Software nicht gut ist, als auch der Umgang mit der Veröffentlichung noch zu wünschen übrig lässt, sage ich mal, jetzt ganz diplomatisch.
Ja, genau. Also der Punkt ist, als Benutzer möchte ich natürlich wissen, dass da ein Problem besteht. Und ich möchte natürlich auch von meinem Anbieter, vor allem wenn er mir suggeriert, hier ist ein sicheres System, möchte ich darüber informiert werden. Und der einzige Punkt, warum das vielleicht nicht passiert ist, weil man dann hätte auf die Webseite schreiben müssen, so Software ist unsicher, das passt nicht ins Marketingkonzept. Bisher ist diese Software kostenlos, aber sie rennen ja auch durch die Zeitung und sagen, sie wissen noch nicht, wie sie es in Zukunft vermarkten wollen. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass da schon finanzielle Aspekte auch im Hintergrund stehen und warum. Also sie haben mir auch auf meine Mail geantwortet, wo sie dann beschrieben haben, warum es nicht open source ist, weil es jetzt gerade so viel Konkurrenz auf dem Markt gibt und sie wollen nicht, dass jemand von ihnen klaut.
Aber klar.
Das lässt so ein bisschen vermuten, dass da schon so langsam diese Idee ist, man könnte da auf Dauer Geld mit verdienen.
Eine Geschichte also, wie der Umgang mit Wendat sein kann. Nexus, vielen Dank.
Bitte schön.
Und viel Spaß noch. Und bitte auch den nächsten Messenger, der das sicherheitsverspricht.
Am Ende haben die ja diese Probleme, die Existenz der Probleme, haben sie ja kommuniziert, aber nur an einen sehr kleinen Kreis, oder?
Ja, sie haben das nur mit der Presse kommuniziert und sie haben auf ihrer Webseite, findet man ganz unten in der Fußzeile, so ein Pressepaket. Also wenn man das runterlädt in diesem ZIP-File, was man dann auspackt, da steht das tatsächlich drin. Und da steht auch, dass sie das alles beseitigt haben und da erklären sie auch irgendwie, wie sie das beseitigt haben, glaube ich grob. Also ich habe das nun mal überflogen.
Und dann stellst du dich hin und sagst, sie haben das nicht öffentlich kommuniziert, ja?
Ja Moment, sie haben es nicht den Usern kommuniziert. Sie haben es öffentlich kommuniziert, klar. Sie haben natürlich von den ganzen Medien wahrscheinlich gleich Mails bekommen, hier, was sagt ihr dazu? Also sie haben ja Heise gegenüber was gesagt, sie haben GoalLab gegenüber was gesagt und so weiter. Also da sind ja schon Antworten gekommen. Sie haben sich auch hingestellt und mir vorgeworfen, ich hätte ja vorher mit ihnen sprechen können. Klar, also da ist schon in den Medien was kommuniziert worden, aber nicht gegenüber den Benutzern. Und das ist genau das, was in der Summe passiert.
Falls Sie das noch nachholen wollen, 031 77 97 110, das ist die Telefonnummer dieser Sendung, könnt ihr gerne noch anrufen, liebe WhistleIRM-Macher. Ja, Nexus, aber gut, das war's jetzt, oder? Vielen Dank. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss. So, jetzt hattest du Thorsten CryptoCat angesprochen. Was ist das und was kann man da erzählen an dieser Geschichte?
Ja, ich habe mich nicht so sehr im Detail damit beschäftigt. Ich habe das nur am Rande mitbekommen, dass es da eben eine Plattform gab, mit der man verschlüsselt kommunizieren kann und die auch von vielen Leuten empfohlen wurde, dass man die eben benutzt, um verschlüsselt zu kommunizieren. Das ist eben einfach mal so der Hintergrund dahinter. Und das wurde wohl offenbar auch ziemlich vielen Journalisten in Krisenregionen eben auch empfohlen zur Kommunikation. Und dann hatte man da irgendwie schwerwiegende Fehler in der Krypto gefunden oder zumindest in der Implementierung. Und ja, also was ich halt so am Rande mitbekomme, aber ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe mich da gar nicht so sehr reingekniet, aber das hat ja doch irgendwie mal im Größeren die Runde gemacht. Also der Entwickler dieser Software oder dieses Verfahrens hatte sich dann halt am Ende mit dem ganzen Feedback auseinandergesetzt und hat halt sein Bestes getan, um halt auch zu recherchieren und herauszufinden, wie er das verbessern kann. Und hat sich im Sommer diesen Jahres auf jeden Fall auf der SIGINT, also einer CCC-Veranstaltung in Köln, auch der kritischen Masse gestellt. Er hatte da einen Vortrag drüber gehalten und hat halt auch vor allen Dingen darüber referiert, was für Lehren er aus diesem ganzen Prozess gezogen hat und wie er das halt in Zukunft vermeiden möchte, dass das eben nochmal passiert oder eben wie man eben auch mit so einem Security Advisories dann am Ende auch umgeht. Also da hat er sich irgendwie einmal in einem Talk hat er darüber erzählt und am Ende hat er sogar nochmal außerplanmäßig eben eine Art Diskussion geführt mit den Leuten, die da auch Interesse dran hatten. Das fand ich halt zum Beispiel sehr positiv im Gegensatz zu eben solchen Leuten, über die wir jetzt gerade was gehört haben, wie die eben damit umgehen, wo möglicherweise andere Interessen dahinterstehen. Eben nicht, dass man etwas besser machen will und anderen eine Kommunikationsplattform zur Verfügung stellen will aus reiner nächsten Liebe, sondern dass man dann möglicherweise auch noch erwartet, dass dann irgendwann mal Geld bei abfällt.
Der Krypto-Card ist ja, glaube ich, wenn ich es richtig sehe, auch sozusagen so eine Sache, wo nicht primär Geld mit verdient wird, sondern ist ja glaube ich umsonst. Genau, also Positivbeispiel. So, jetzt hast du ja hier noch eine relativ lange Liste an Dingen mitgebracht, an kleinen Anekdoten, die man vielleicht so halbe erzählen könnte. Es scheint doch alles nicht so einfach zu sein.
Nee, ist auch nicht so einfach. Also, ich meine, viele Sachen, die man zum Beispiel an irgendeinen Hersteller kommuniziert, die findet man möglicherweise ja auch im Rahmen seiner normalen beruflichen Tätigkeit als Sicherheitsberater oder eben jemand, der eben Software zerpflückt und da ganz skizziert nach Fehlern sucht. Also, das ist halt mein Job. Im Grunde genommen kommen halt Kunden von mir an, die sagen, wir wollen in unserem Netzwerk diese und jene Software installieren und ausrollen für alle Benutzer. Das kann dann halt durchaus mehrere Zehntausende Benutzer betreffen, irgendwelche Managementsoftware und so weiter. Und die kommen dann eben zu uns an und sagen, okay, bevor wir uns, bevor wir jetzt hier viel Geld ausgeben und diese Software über uns im Netzwerk installieren, schaut euch doch mal diese Installation an und sagt uns, was ihr davon haltet aus Sicherheitssicht. Weil wir wollen zumindest wissen, auf was für einem Sicherheitsniveau sich dieses Produkt befindet, damit man eben weiß, was man am Ende noch dazu investieren muss, um Sicherheitsrisiken abzuschwächen und eben damit umgehen zu können. Dass man eben mit so einer größeren Komplexität sich auch noch größere Risiken und so Angriffsflächen eben ins eigene Netzwerk holt.
Also es ist gar nicht so, dass man davon ausgeht in diesem Kontext, dass eine Software komplett sicher ist. Man will nur wissen, in welchem Level sie ungefähr operiert.
Ja, ich meine, jemand, der uns mit so etwas beauftragt oder irgendeinen anderen beliebigen Sicherheitsdienstleister, der hat ein gewisses Budget für diese Überprüfung und im Rahmen dieses Budgets kann man dann eben agieren. Manchmal findet man Bugs schneller, manchmal nicht so schnell, manchmal findet man vieler, manchmal weniger. Aber im Endeffekt hat der Kunde, der das beauftragt, auch nur einen Überblick. Wenn ich jetzt zwei Hacker da hinsetze und die dafür bezahle, da drinne Bugs zu finden, dann kostet das so und so viel Geld. Und am Ende kommt das und das raus. Aber im Rahmen solcher Tätigkeiten findet man ja auch an der Regel Bugs, die man dann auch dem Hersteller dieser Software am Ende auch kommuniziert, damit der das Produkt verbessern kann. Da hat dann jeder was davon. Der Kunde von uns, der diese Software kaufen will, der lernt auch gleich mal den Kunden eben von der Seite kennen, wie reagiert der auf so eine Bugreports und wie schnell ist der in der Lage, Patches bereitzustellen und ja.
Und kannst du da Beispiele geben, was dafür passiert ist?
Das Ding ist halt, dass man da natürlich nicht sagen kann, man macht hier Full Disclosure, weil damit tut man ja dann seinen Kunden auch nicht um den großen Gefallen. Das läuft dann alles sehr gesittet ab und in den meisten Fällen kommt es dann auch in der Regel nicht zu irgendwelchen Veröffentlichungen, weil man da manchmal auch Sachen findet, die halt, wo es halt schlecht wäre, die zu veröffentlichen. Aber das ist halt, weiß ich nicht. Also in vielen Fällen findet man halt Sachen, die man auch veröffentlichen kann, aber dann ist man halt in einem sehr engen Kontakt mit diesem Hersteller, dieser Software und fängt da halt jetzt nicht an großartig rumzuzicken. Damit man halt auch, ich meine, das ist ja, man agiert ja da nicht anonym, sondern man hat ja auch einen Ruf. Und wenn wir uns dann da eben professionell verhalten, dann beugen wir uns halt eben den Regeln und müssen halt einfach gucken, dass wir da nicht zu sehr negativ auffallen. Manchmal kommt es dann aber eben zu so einer Situation, wo wir denken, das ist vielleicht einfach nur so ein Beiprodukt von irgendeiner Tätigkeit, die man halt gerade macht, dann findet man irgendeinen völlig banalen Fehler in irgendeinem total weit verbreiteten Betriebssystem für mobile Telefone. Und dann schreibt man einfach einen Blogartikel darüber, wenn man einfach auch nicht einsieht, dass man für so einen banalen Fehler jetzt irgendwie so diesen Prozess mit Responsible Disclosure oder so durchspielt, weil das vielleicht einfach ein bisschen zu... Damit würde man den eigenen Bug, den man da gefunden hat, vielleicht einfach ein bisschen zu sehr pushen und ein bisschen zu stark aufwerten. Und das ist es einfach auch in der Regel nicht wert, gerade bei so was, was wir mal veröffentlicht haben, ist halt, dass wir einfach durch einen Zufall herausgefunden haben, dass bei HTC die Mail-Applikationen SSL-Zertifikate nicht ordentlich validiert und dass man da halt spielend leicht mehr in den Sinn mittel machen kann, also sich einfach in die Kommunikation zwischen dem Telefon und dem Mail-Server einhängen kann.
Obwohl SSL sagen, eigentlich wird die Mail verschlüsselt übertragen, aber das hat einen Fehler, dass man das sozusagen doch abhören kann. Und das habt ihr dann gleich öffentlich gemacht.
Ja, weil das einfach ein völlig banaler Fehler war. Und diesen Fehler, den gab es halt schon mal vor ein paar Jahren und offenbar gab es dann aber einfach viele Benutzer, die sich darüber aufgeregt haben, dass denen häufiger SSL-Warnings angezeigt wurden. Also einfach nur Warnmeldungen, dass irgendwas mit dem SSL-Zertifikat nicht in Ordnung ist. Dass sich HDC am Ende genötigt sah, diese Sicherheitschecks wieder auszuschalten. Das ist halt nichts, was man dann so aus Versehen macht. Wenn das aus Versehen passiert, dann muss man sich schon grundlegend überlegen, was haben die denn da für Softwareentwicklungsprozesse eigentlich? Wie machen die das? Haben die keine Test-Cases? Wenn sie mal einen Bug haben, also in der Regel haben ja so Firmen, die das auch ordentlich machen, die kriegen halt mal eine Bug-Meldung rein, dann bauen die sich einen Test-Case und überprüfen halt jede Revision, die sie veröffentlichen, gegen diese ganzen Test-Cases. Um halt auch zu verhindern, dass der gleiche Fehler nochmal veröffentlicht wird. Also das scheint schon eine sehr mutwillige Sache gewesen zu sein, die wahrscheinlich darauf beruht, dass Benutzer faul sind oder einfach zu blöd sind, Fehlermeldungen durchzulesen. Da haben wir halt gesagt, was sollen wir da ein Advisory machen, das ist halt albern.
Jetzt habt ihr das sozusagen einfach so veröffentlicht, gab es eine Reaktion von der HTC?
Ja, natürlich gab es eine Reaktion. Irgendwann bekamen wir dann halt eine Mail vom Legal Department, die halt so anfingen mit Gentlemen, wir müssen mal über eure Disclosure Policies sprechen. Und ja, also einfach auch nicht unbedingt nett. Aber gut, ich meine, was wir da veröffentlicht haben, war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt nett. Aber ich hielt das halt einfach für albern, da irgendwie so diese Riesenprozedur durchzuziehen mit Irresponsible Disclosure. Da gibt es einfach andere Sachen. Da macht man sich diese Mühe dann halt einfach lieber, weil das einfach vielleicht mehr Impact hat und mehr Spaß macht.
Ist das denn mittlerweile gefixt worden?
Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Habt ihr denn was, was noch kritischer ist, aber immer noch rumliegt, obwohl ihr schon seit Jahren darauf hinweist?
Was heißt seit Jahren darauf hinweisen?
Ich denke ja an Punkt 4 der ominösen Liste, die niemand kennt.
Ich wollte jetzt ja eigentlich nicht irgendeine Liste abarbeiten, sondern einfach nur... Das ist aber in der Tat einfach ein ganz interessantes Beispiel. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was wir da am Ende für eine Strategie hatten, das zu veröffentlichen. Eigentlich war das mal so Responsible Disclosure ganz am Anfang, aber das ist halt schon ein paar Jahre her. 2009 oder 2008 hatte mein Kollege angefangen, sich mal so Wireless-Keyboards anzugucken von Microsoft. Also einfach so drahtlose Tastaturen, wo man dann eben die batteriebetriebene Tastatur auf einem sauberen Schreibtisch stehen hat. Man tippt eine Taste und magischerweise taucht dann dieser Buchstabe auch auf dem Monitor auf. Da hat er sich halt mal diese angeguckt, wie werden diese Daten eigentlich übertragen und kann man das irgendwie abfangen. Und als er dann ziemlich schnell herausgefunden hat, wie das geht und wie man das abfangen kann, hat er sich da entsprechend halt auch an den Hersteller gewendet, in dem Fall halt Microsoft. Microsoft hat da zwar am Anfang drauf reagiert, aber dann ist das irgendwann auch ziemlich schnell wieder eingeschlafen. Und dann ist er damit halt auf diverse Konferenzen, hat halt Sachen veröffentlicht und Proof of Concept haben wir dann gebaut und veröffentlicht, also einfach ein Stück Hardware gebaut, was in der Lage ist, diese Daten, die übertragen werden, mitzulesen. Wir haben Code veröffentlicht und die Hardware. Und das hat immer noch keinen interessiert. Die Reaktion war halt so, man muss halt in der Nähe sein und das ist ja nicht so richtig remote und überhaupt. Und irgendwann später hat Microsoft eine neue Generation von Keyboards gebaut, die sehr viel zuverlässiger funktionieren. Also diese alten Keyboards basierten auf irgendeinem alten Funk, also so ein Elfmeterband, 27 MHz hatten die halt benutzt, um Daten zu übertragen. Sie hatten halt so einen lustigen XOR-Krypto mit einem Byte-Key.
Was auch immer das bedeutet, also man konnte sehr leicht mithören.
Ja, ja, also es ist halt so wie rot 13 oder so. Also es ist halt wirklich nicht sonderlich, also es ist halt einfach zu analysieren und mitzulesen. Nur irgendwann hatten sie halt neue Geräte gebaut, die hatten irgendwie andere Funktechnik an Bord. Die haben dann eben so eine 2, 4 Gigahertz Funkchips drauf gehabt, die sehr wenig Strom verbrauchen, die sehr schnell sind. Und dann haben sie da damit gearbeitet, haben eine neue Krypto implementiert. Und wir haben uns natürlich dann diese Keyboards auch angesehen und haben halt auch relativ schnell herausgefunden, wie man diesen Verkehr mitlesen kann und wie diese Krypto funktioniert. Da hatten sie halt nicht nur einen einen Byte langen XOR-Key, sondern einen fünf Byte langen XOR-Key.
Das heißt, das ist ein bisschen besser, aber immer noch weiter von entfernt richtig gut zu sein.
Und dieser XOR-Key war gleichzeitig die MAC-Adresse des Gerätes. Und ja, damit war das im Endeffekt Klartext, was da übermittelt wird. Der Vorteil bei diesen Tastaturen war halt, man konnte dadurch, dass man diese Module, die da fürs Senden genutzt werden, die sind halt sehr einfach als Modul zu erwerben oder eben auch zu bauen. Und dann hat man am Ende nicht nur einen Empfänger, dass man alles mitsniffen kann, also mitlesen kann, was da eingetippt wird, wie zum Beispiel Passwörter oder irgendwelche Bankkreditkartennummern und so weiter. Wir konnten auch senden. Das heißt, wenn wir einmal irgendwie herausgefunden haben, wie dieser Crypto-Key aussieht und wie diese MAC-Adresse aussieht, dann konnte man halt auch Code ausführen auf dem PC.
Warte mal, verstehe ich richtig zu sagen, also drahtlose Tastaturen kann man sowohl mitlesen, was da jemand auf der Tastatur schreibt, als auch einfach dem Computer, sagen Signale sind, und so tun, als wäre man die Tastatur.
Ja, ja, genau.
Das geht immer noch?
Das geht immer noch, natürlich. Also, ich meine, je nachdem, was du da für eine Tastatur hast. Aber du kannst im Grunde genommen einfach mit deiner Richtfunkantenne draußen im Auto sitzen, warten, bis der Typ aufs Klo geht. Und dann kannst du sagen, ich bin die Tastatur und jetzt führ mal diesen Befehl aus. Und dann kannst du da irgendeine Schadsoftware ausführen.
Und Microsoft hat dazu gesagt, das ist doch alles nicht so schlimm.
Nö, das haben die so nicht gesagt, aber die haben es halt auch einschlafen lassen. Ich vermute halt einfach, sie sitzen es aus, weil sie einfach nichts tun können. Was sollen sie tun? Also diese Geräte sehen halt nicht vor, da irgendwie Firmware-Updates einzuspielen. Und vermutlich wurden die halt nicht mal selber von Microsoft gebaut, sondern irgendwo eingekauft, kommen halt von irgendwo her. Die Hardware wird irgendwo eingekauft und die Firmware halt auch. Und man kann es halt einfach nicht patchen. Und wenn man es nicht patchen kann, kann man entweder die ganze Produktpalette zurückrufen oder das einfach aussitzen. Und das ist im Grunde genommen das, was passiert ist.
Habt ihr das dann auch schon Full Disclosured?
Ja, das ist alles. Also was heißt Full Disclosure? Tatsächlich haben wir Microsoft davon in Kenntnis gesetzt, dass wir jetzt auch diese Keyboards gehackt haben und dass wir das da und da veröffentlichen werden. Aber ich meine, die Leute sind ja nicht unfreundlich mit uns. Sie haben halt auch darauf reagiert, aber am Ende heißt es halt so, man muss in der Nähe sein und damit ist die Sache hier.
Okay, was sind eure Tests? Was heißt in der Nähe?
Also in der Nähe heißt es halt irgendwie so, je nach Gebäude, also was das für Fenster und Wände sind, können es durchaus 20, 30, 40, 50 Meter sein.
Ein schönes Beispiel für eine Sicherheitslücke, wo vielleicht ein bisschen mehr öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit noch wünschenswert wäre. So, wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde für Sicherheitslücken und im Umgang machen aber jetzt eine kurze Pause hier im Chaosradio mit dem Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
In unserer Reihe absolute Superstars. Montag, 28. Einer von die absoluten Superstars.
Mit Philipp Berger. Die 5 UN-Veto-Mächte USA, Großbritannien, Frankreich, Russland und China beraten gerade über die Krise in Syrien. Sie diskutieren über einen britischen Resolutionsentwurf, der einen Militäreinsatz erlauben würde. Daran heißt es, es müssten alle notwendigen Maßnahmen zum Schutz von Zivilpersonen vor Giftgas ergriffen werden. Nach den Worten des britischen Premierministers Cameron gibt es keine eindeutigen Beweise, dass der syrische Machthaber Assad den mutmaßlichen Chemiewaffeneinsatz angeordnet hat. Er, Cameron, sei aber von der Schuld der Regierung in Damaskus überzeugt, sagte der britische Regierungschef im Parlament in London. In Brandenburg gibt es offenbar mehr Opfer rechtsextremistischer Gewalt als bisher angenommen. Bei Recherchen des Potsdamer Moses Mendelsohn Zentrums sind neun zusätzliche Verdachtsfälle aufgetaucht. Die Wissenschaftler untersuchen im Auftrag des Innenministeriums derzeit 31 Tötungsverbrechen seit der Wende, bei denen von einem rechtsextremistischen Hintergrund ausgegangen wird. Dabei stießen die Forscher auf diese weiteren neun Verdachtsfälle. Die Grünen in Berlin haben einen Antrag für eine offizielle Marihuana-Verkaufsstelle im Görlitzer Park in Kreuzberg gestellt. Das Bezirksparlament von Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg muss den Antrag für dieses Modellprojekt jetzt prüfen. In dem Laden soll, wie in den niederländischen Coffee-Shops, Cannabis kontrolliert verkauft werden. Im Görlitzer Park gibt es seit Jahren illegalen Drogenhandel. In letzter Zeit häufen sich Polizeirazzien. Anwohner sagen, dass die Zahl der Dealer und Konsumenten zugenommen hat. Jugendliche haben in Deutschland deutlich weniger Freizeit als noch vor drei Jahren. Das zeigt der aktuelle Freizeitmonitor, den die Stiftung für Zukunftsfragen in Berlin vorgestellt hat. Durchschnittlich vier Stunden Freizeit pro Tag haben Jugendliche. Das sind knapp 50 Minuten weniger als noch vor drei Jahren. Die Autoren der Studie erklären das damit, dass es immer mehr Ganztagsschulen gibt und dass der Leistungsdruck allgemein gestiegen sei, z.B. durch das Abi in zwölf Jahren. Zudem hätten Jugendliche heute mehr Termine und stünden unter dem Druck, ständig online aktiv zu sein. Fußball-Bundesligist Eintracht Frankfurt hat die Gruppenphase der Europa League erreicht. Die Hessen gewannen das Playoff-Rückspiel gegen Karabach Akdam aus Aserbaidschan mit 2 zu 1. Der VfB Stuttgart dagegen hat den direkten Einzug in die Europa League verpasst. Die Schwaben kamen gegen Rijeka aus Kroatien nicht über ein 2 zu 2 hinaus. Stuttgart könnte mit Glück morgen als Ersatz für den türkischen Vizemeister Fenebahce Istanbul ausgelost werden und somit durch die Hintertür doch noch am Wettbewerb teilnehmen. Berlin-Wilmersdorf, 14 Grad, Treptow genauso, Forst 10, Angermünde 13, Rate nur 15 und Frankfurt oder 16 Grad. Kälter als 9 Grad soll diese Nacht nicht werden. Am Freitag dann Morgen gibt's viel Sonne und nur wenige Wolken bei maximal 25 Grad. Es bleibt trocken. Am Wochenende verdichten sich die Wolken, die Sonne scheint nur noch selten. Dabei nimmt es zum Sonntag hin die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit zu und es wird kühler. Berlin A100, der Stadtring in Richtung Wedding. Zwischen Beusselstraße und Seestraße gibt's stockenden Verkehr. Und Neukölln A100, Stadtring bis 5 Uhr früh finden im Britzertunnel Wartungsarbeiten statt. Deshalb ist der Stadtring statt Einwärts zwischen Buschkukallee und Oberlandstraße gesperrt. Treptow die Kiefholzstraße, da ist nur eine Spur frei in beiden Richtungen zwischen Baumschulenweg, Baumschulenstraße und Rigsdorfer Straße. Und ein Hinweis für morgen früh Moabit, die Turmstraße wird zwischen Strom- und Waldstraße ab 6 Uhr früh bis einschließlich Sonntag wegen eines Straßenfestes in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Busse werden umgeleitet. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit manchen.
Heute Chaosradio mit Thorsten und Andreas Hallo und guten Abend. Noch mal zum letzten Mal.
Hallo.
Noch mal hallo.
Sehr schön macht ihr das. Und es geht heute um die Veröffentlichung von Sicherheitslücken. Das heißt, wie geht man eigentlich damit um, wenn man so eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden hat? Und wie reagieren die Firmen darauf? Und wir haben gerade schon gehört nicht immer so gut. Wir haben vielleicht noch ein paar kleine Geschichten. Und ich möchte jetzt auch noch aufrufen, anzurufen. Das heißt, wenn ihr noch etwas nicht verstanden habt oder genauer erklärt haben wollt, dann könnt ihr nochmal anrufen. Oder wenn ihr selber Geschichten habt über lustige Computerfehler, die zu seltsamen Bedienelementen führten. 0331 70 97 11 Zoll. Wir hören hier erst noch mal eine kleine Musik, und zwar Amen von Lim. Eimen von Liem hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, wo es heute um die Bekanntgabe von Sicherheitsglücken geht, nachdem wir den theoretischen Teil geklärt haben. Also was da wem passieren kann, haben wir noch vielleicht die eine oder andere kleine Geschichte zum Ende der Sendung. Thorsten, du hast jetzt noch eine kleine Geschichte, wo du gar nicht sagen darfst, um wen es da geht, aber die trotzdem spannend ist.
Naja, spannend nicht. Aber das ist halt einfach so ein typisches Beispiel, wo man sich dann einfach echt ärgert, wie diese Kommunikation mit diesem Softwarehersteller läuft, der von sich behauptet, bislang noch keine Sicherheitslücken gehabt zu haben.
Aha, okay, wir haben also einen Softwarehersteller, der behauptet, noch keine Sicherheitslücke gehabt zu haben. Was habt ihr da gefunden? Eine Sicherheitslücke?
Ja, natürlich haben wir eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden, die eigentlich total trivial auch wiederum ist, auch trivial zu fixen eigentlich. Aber der Impact ist halt relativ hoch bei dem. Wir hatten dann mit diesem Hersteller Kontakt aufgenommen. Wir wurden quasi beauftragt von einem Kunden, der diese Software potenziell einsetzen möchte. Wir sollen uns das mal angucken. Wir haben das natürlich dann alles mit unserem Kunden besprochen. Wie gehen wir auf den Hersteller dieser Software zu? Das wurde dann koordiniert mit dem Kunden. Dann gucken wir einfach, wie reagieren die?
Ihr habt einen Kunden, der eine Software kaufen will, will aber sicher gehen, dass sie gut ist. Deswegen beauftragt er euch, diese Software anzugucken. Der Kunde besorgt die Software, gibt die euch. Dann habt ihr den Fehler gefunden, habt das aber erst mal mit dem Kunden besprochen.
Genau. Dann arbeiten wir zusammen mit dem Kunden eine Strategie aus, wie wir den Hersteller dieser Software darüber informieren, weil wir wollen natürlich, dass er die Probleme behebt. Wir wollen natürlich auch lernen, wie verhält er sich mit Problemen. Wie reagiert er, wie schnell kann man mit Patches rechnen. Das war eigentlich alles total entspannt. Es gab dann Telefonkonferenzen und E-Mails ohne Ende, wo immer wieder gesagt wird, wie wir vorgehen. Wir werden das dann auch veröffentlichen, damit andere Nutzer dieser Software die Gelegenheit bekommen, über so einen schwerwiegenden Fehler informiert zu werden. Das ging ja noch mal so hin und her. Dann hat man ja irgendwie so eine Zeitlinie, die man dann auch immer wieder neu kommuniziert und abstimmt. Dann sagen alle ja, ja und alles ist gut. Dann sagt man, wenn ihr einen Patch habt, dann werden wir das veröffentlichen und nicht vorher, weil das ist so verantwortungsvoll. Wir veröffentlichen den Kram erst, wenn ihr einen Patch habt. Irgendwann hat der Hersteller gesagt, alles klar, wir haben das Problem verstanden, wir haben das Problem behoben, wir haben hier einen Patch, den kann man ausrollen. Dann sagen wir, alles klar, dann können wir in zwei Wochen veröffentlichen. Und dann fängt es an komisch zu werden, weil dann heißt es auf einmal so, wie ihr wollt das veröffentlichen? Wo wollt ihr das veröffentlichen? Ich will nur sicherstellen, dass das jetzt nicht auf irgendeiner öffentlichen Webseite veröffentlicht wird. Tat dann halt ganz überrascht und fing dann halt an, da rum zu diskutieren. Also nur mal so von einem juristischen Standpunkt aus betrachtet, seid ihr euch wirklich sicher, dass ihr euch da nicht irgendwie juristische Probleme bereitet? Also ich meine, ich bin jetzt kein Anwalt, aber ich könnte ja unsere Anwälte mal fragen, was die dazu sagen würden, wenn ihr anfängt, da jetzt hier Fehler zu veröffentlichen. Weil wir haben ja in unseren Geschäftsbedingungen ja auch stehen, dass man die Software nicht reverse engineern darf und dass man da nicht gezielt nach unseren Geheimnissen suchen darf und so weiter und so ging das dann halt los. Und dann ging das Ganze schon wieder auf irgendwie so eine juristische Schiene. Und bei uns ist dann natürlich so, also im Endeffekt war so die Kernaussage von diesen Kunden sinngemäß an uns gerichtet, einen schönen Kunden haben sie da, das wäre doch schade, wenn diesem Kunden irgendwas zustößt. Ich meine, sie haben uns im Endeffekt unter Druck gesetzt, weil wir natürlich Gefahr laufen, unseren Kunden zu verlieren, der uns ja bezahlt dafür. Und ich meine, das ist halt einfach dann echt, das riecht dann halt einfach nach Schlammschlacht. Und das ist einfach total ätzend, wenn die dann anfangen, überrascht zu tun. Und da hat man dann auch irgendwann keine Freude mehr dran und denkt sich einfach nur so, hey, jetzt das Ding einfach irgendwie anonym veröffentlichen oder was weiß ich, das wäre halt eine total tolle Sache, kann man natürlich nicht machen. Aber es ist halt schon dann echt mühsam da, irgendwie locker zu bleiben.
Gibt es da schon eine Lösung des Problems oder ist das quasi noch im Schwange?
Das ist total unklar, informiert uns ja dann jetzt auch nicht.
Wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich daran schuld, wenn so ein Fehler dann in die Öffentlichkeit kommt? Also gibt es das wirklich? Also kann ja tatsächlich noch passieren, irgendjemand anderes sagt hier selber Fehler, zack Öffentlichkeit. Wer wird denn dann dafür verantwortlich gemacht? Geht das überhaupt?
Werden wahrscheinlich dann irgendwelche Gerichte klären, keine Ahnung. Also was halt total ätzend ist, wenn man eben auf so eine Firmen zugeht und sagt, die wollen, also man hat da einen Fehler, dann kommen die halt gleich mit so diesen Geheimhaltungsvereinbarungen an und so weiter. Das ist halt Gang und Gebe. Also da werden schon einige Leute von Anfang an mundtot mitgemacht und damit gibt man quasi die Möglichkeit schon mal ab, überhaupt irgendwas zu veröffentlichen, weil die haben dann einfach alles gegen dich in die Hand, in der Hand. Und das kann dann einfach um viel Geld gehen.
Das heißt, die nehmen erst, bevor überhaupt was geredet wird, hier Zettel auf dem Tisch, unterschreib mal.
Was total hirnrissig ist, weil du kriegst ja keine Information von dem Softwarehersteller, du gibst dem Softwarehersteller Information über Fehler, die er noch nicht kennt. Also es ist einfach eine verkehrte Welt, aber das ist halt so eine Realität. Und da muss man halt einfach aufpassen, wenn man da auch unerfahren ist, so eine Dinge zu submetten, also einfach dem auf Hersteller zuzugehen.
Okay, das ist die juristische Keule. Andreas hat noch eine Geschichte mitgebracht, wie man es nicht macht, wenn man der ist, der den Fehler rausgefunden hat.
Eine kleine Warnung an Leute da draußen. Ich will nicht vergemeinern, aber es gibt manche Nerds, die kennen Subtext nicht, die sprechen einfach Klartext. Und da kam eines Tages jemand zu einer großen Firma und sagte, schön guten Tag, ich habe deine Sicherheitslücke gefunden, das und das. Und ich will euch ja nicht erpressen, aber es wäre schön, wenn ich ein bisschen Geld dafür sehen würde. Er meinte das wörtlich genau so.
Er meinte tatsächlich im vollen Ernst, ich will euch nicht erpressen, aber wenn ihr mir was springen lasst, das wäre schon cool.
Genau, das meinte er. Das war sozusagen das, was er versuchte zu sagen. Aber was natürlich irgendwie als Subtext rüberkam, ist, ich will euch sehr wohl erpressen. Ja, und das endete dann damit, dass er also kein Geld bekommen hat und auch kein Ansehen, sondern irgendwie 40 Tagessätze gemeinnützige Arbeit ableisten musste. Weil da kam dann gleich das LKA und die ganze Nummer.
Das war also nicht irgendeine Wald-
und Wiesn-Firma? Das war, nee, das war ein großes deutsches Unternehmen, ja.
So machen wir es also nicht.
Genau, also so größere Unternehmen haben dann Corporate Security und das sind auch Leute, die nicht so ganz die nettesten Zeitgenossen sind.
Jetzt stellt man sich die Frage, also klar, wenn man wie Thorsten in der Firma arbeitet, hat man damit eh zu tun, aber wie ist denn das jetzt, wenn man so aufstrebender Junghacker ist und sich so ein System mal angeguckt hat, so eine Software, und denkt, da ist ja ganz schön was kaputt. Wir hatten ganz am Anfang die Möglichkeit besprochen, dass man auch versuchen kann, so was zu verkaufen, was aber sozusagen aus moralischen Gründen verwerflich ist. Ist das eigentlich so? Ich habe es jetzt gerade so festgelegt. Seht ihr das auch so?
Wer ist denn der Käuferkreis? Was schätzt du denn? Wer kauft denn Software-Schwachstellen?
Ihr habt mir vorhin erklärt, Software-Schwachstellen kaufen entweder Kriminelle oder Regierungen, die damit schöne Überwachungssoftware bauen. Deswegen habe ich auch gerade festgelegt, ich finde es moralisch verwerflich. Aber ist das Konsens?
Das ist nicht ganz Konsens. Es gibt da Leute, die sagen, ach, moralisch, moralisch, mir alles egal, so ist ja irgendwie mein Geld. Oder irgendwie, besonders in den USA verbreitet, aber gibt es auch woanders aufrechte Patrioten, die sagen, natürlich müssen wir irgendwie die Terroristen hacken. Natürlich müssen dazu Waffen gebaut werden und ich baue hier die Waffen, um die Terroristen zu hacken.
Okay, gut, das kann man also machen und ich finde es trotzdem nicht empfehlenswert. Und dann ist es mit dieser Veröffentlichung, die aber, wenn ich euch jetzt richtig verstanden habe, schon sehr steinig sein kann. Was ist denn für euch, wenn jemand, der so sagen, der keine Erfahrung damit hat, aber jetzt über so ein Ding gestolpert ist, die Möglichkeit, das zu machen? Also irgendwie Nexus haben wir gehört, der hat ja sozusagen einfach mal einen Blogpost geschrieben, den Hubs ganz schnell ganz viel Öffentlichkeit gemacht hat, war vielleicht auch sozusagen ein bisschen schnell. Er meinte auch, das sei so halb schief gegangen oder war gar nicht so geplant. Was ist denn jetzt ein guter Weg mit so einer Sache umzugehen?
Na ja, wenn man selbst schon von sich den Eindruck hat, dass man vielleicht diesem Druck nicht standhalten kann, dann sollte man sich vielleicht jemanden suchen, mit dem man das gemeinsam einfach mal durchspielen kann, einfach durchdiskutieren kann, einfach jemand, der vielleicht auch einen Namen hat. Ich meine, es gab ja häufiger eben Situationen, wo man eben gerade bei so größeren Geschichten, die halt auch durchaus Impact haben oder die eben einen finanziellen Schaden bei bestimmten Firmen hervorrufen könnten, dass man dann sich einfach jemanden sucht, der einen dabei so ein bisschen unterstützt, der auch ein bisschen vielleicht bekannter ist oder halt auch über entsprechende Mittel verfügt, etwaige juristische Verfahren ein bisschen finanziell abzufangen oder abzufedern.
Hört es sich jetzt an nach einer Telefonsilzsorge für Junghacker?
Tatsächlich bieten wir das auf dem Kongress regelmäßig an. Da gibt es also so ein Telefon, wo man anrufen kann und sagen kann, ich habe gehackt was jetzt und bekommt dann diskrete Beratungen, wie man aus der Nummer möglichst elegant rauskommt.
Aber im Ernst, ist der Chaos Computer Club da jetzt Ansprechpartner, dass man sagen kann, ich habe eine krasse Sicherheitslücke bei Betriebssystem XY gefunden, traue mich aber nicht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ist auch schon mehr verfolgt.
Ich meine, guck dir den Staatstrojaner an. Es ist ja im Grunde genommen eine ähnliche Sache. Also jemand weiß halt nicht, da kann halt was sein. Und wie gehen wir eigentlich daran? Was machen wir damit? Also wir brauchen einen technischen Sachverstand. Wir müssen das irgendwie kommunizieren können. Und wir brauchen irgendwie eine Organisation, die in der Lage ist, das, was da möglicherweise kommen mag, irgendwie abzufedern. Also das ist halt ein gutes Beispiel. Aber es gab ja auch irgendwie andere Projekte, wo der CCC sich im Endeffekt auch dahinter gestellt hat und geholfen hat, eben Dinge zu veröffentlichen und so ein bisschen das Rückgrat gebildet hat von Dingen, die dann veröffentlicht wurden. Ich weiß nicht, diese Wahlstifte waren eine Nummer, glaube ich, wo der CCC halt auch irgendwie sich da engagiert hat und Dinge getan hat, die ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so das Paradebeispiel dafür.
Also man kann aber, wenn man sowas entdeckt hat, schon zu euch kommen.
Ja natürlich, aber man sollte sich vielleicht schon auch überlegen, dass man eben nicht mit jedem Quatsch irgendwie gleich so ein großes Fass aufmachen sollte. Also wie ich schon meinte, es gibt durchaus auch Dinge, wo ich mir sage, das ist einfach völlig banal, da braucht man diesen Aufwand nicht treiben, das ist halt Pille-Palle. Und da muss man schon selber so ein bisschen abschätzen können. Also ich meine, man muss jetzt nicht wegen irgendeinem SQL-Injection-Bug in irgendeiner Web-Software dann irgendwie anfangen, hier mit dem CCC in Kontakt zu treten. Das sollte man vielleicht...
Also wenn man einfach nur eine Webseite aufmacht, dann kann man das einfach dahin mehlen, meinst du?
Nein, CCC hat ja keine... Naja, ist halt nicht so die Seelsorge in dem Sinne. Also ich meine, wenn man irgendwo eine Webseite aufmacht, ja...
Dann ist halt die Webseite auf.
Dann ist die halt auf. Ja, das passiert tausendfach täglich.
Also wenn man Cross-Site-Scripting bei was auch immer für ein Mindestthema auf der Webseite findet, dann kann man das einfach direkt ans PSI melden. Das ist auch in Ordnung. Da passiert auch nichts Schlimmes. Aber wenn es jetzt etwas ist, wo man sich überlegt, so gleich kommen die schwarzen Hubschrauber und Leute seilen sich ab, dann...
Ja, und ich meine, in den USA wurde das ja im Grunde genommen legitimiert. Ich meine, wenn das irgendwie Hacker gibt, die Informationen über Schwachstellen veröffentlichen oder Exploits veröffentlichen, die geeignet sind, die Sicherheit der Vereinigten Staaten zu gefährden und die kritischen Infrastrukturen, da gab es doch irgendwie diesen Beschluss, dass dann eben dieses Kriegsrecht ausgesprochen wird. Und die dann eben ausgelöscht werden können. Also ich meine, das ist halt so der Worst Case in dem Fall.
Hoffen wir, dass euch das nicht passiert. So viel also zur Veröffentlichung von Sicherheitslücken oder zum fachgerechten Umgang mit Herrschaftswissen, könnte man auch sagen. Ihr habt noch zwei kleine Termine mitgebracht, die ihr erzählen wollt, was der CCC so plant.
Genau, eigentlich drei Termine. Zum einen, siebter, neunter ist wieder die Freiheit statt Angst-Demo hier in Berlin. Und wie immer seid ihr alle aufgerufen zu kommen und zu zeigen, dass das mit der Überwachung nicht so toll ist und ihr dagegen seid, wenn euch die NS-Album Telefonsext zuhört.
Dann gibt es noch die MRM CD 2013 in Darmstadt, die am 6. September beginnt.
Was ist das?
Die Meta Rhein-Main-Chaos-Days, das ist sozusagen eine regionale Veranstaltung rund um Frankfurt, Darmstadt, Mainz und wie die Orte da alle heißen.
Und dann haben wir die weniger familiäre Veranstaltung, die da heißt...
Wer hat doch schon wieder jemand sein Handy angemacht?
Ich bin es nicht. Unschuldig. Der 30. Chaos Communication Congress 30C3 in Hamburg steht an und das gibt ein Call for Paper und ihr seid alle noch aufgerufen fleißig Content zu submitten zu den zahlreichen Themen, die wir da halt wie immer haben, also Technik, Politik, Soziales, Kunst, Wissenschaft.
Also wenn ihr noch ein Thema habt für den Chaos Communication Congress, könnt ihr es noch eindanken.
Schickt das bitte rum.
Um die Tickets muss man sich ja also noch keine Sorgen machen.
Ich glaube nicht, aber ich weiß, dass der Kongress auf jeden Fall ziemlich cool werden wird dieses Jahr sowohl von der Location her, also letztes Jahr war die Location ja irgendwie neu für alle, aber es war eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung und ich hoffe, dass es halt dieses Jahr inhaltlich auch noch mehr zu bieten gibt. Das heißt, es wird alles noch ein bisschen größer und mehr Leute und naja, schickt uns mal ein paar coole Paper, damit wir da eine schöne Auswahl haben.
Und vorher hören wir uns aber wahrscheinlich noch in dem einen oder anderen Chaosradio. Das waren Andreas und Thorsten. Vielen Dank euch und viel Spaß noch.
Danke.
Und wir übergeben an Flo Heiler, der jetzt gleich im Night Flight euch mit Punkmusik bewerfen wird. Ihr könnt den ganzen Podcast nochmal nachhören. Auf Fritz, ihr erscheint diese Nacht auf Chaosradio.ccc.de ein bisschen später, aber wird auf jeden Fall auch irgendwann verfügbar sein. Falls ihr noch Anmerkungen habt, gerne auch im dazugehörigen Blog in die Kommentarfunktion schreiben oder an Chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich hab nur noch eine Nachricht für euch. Macht immer schön eure, ne, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.